la séance
est ouverte
pendant que nos collègues s'installent
je tiens à vous présenter à ma gauche
cette dessinateur Louison François
Dorothée Jean-Yves Marielle Cécile et
Coco pelo que nous accueillons
aujourd'hui pour cette première séance
de questions au gouvernement
[Applaudissements]
donc c'est dans
s'il vous plaît mes chers collègues
c'est dans je vous propose que nous
ouvrions ensemble notre assemblée
davantage aux Français et c'est dans
cette démarche d'ouverture que nous
créons aujourd'hui un badge artiste qui
nous permettra d'accueillir des artistes
professionnels et des étudiants qui
pourront venir s'exercer et créer en
direct en regardant notre démocratie
fonctionner
[Applaudissements]
merci
alors s'il vous plaît
en votre nom à tous
je tiens à adresser les félicitations de
la représentation nationale à notre
compatriote Monsieur Alain Aspect
coloréat du prix Nobel de physique 2022
pour ses recherches décisives sur la
mécanique quantique
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie
alors
je vous demande un peu de calme s'il
vous plaît madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les membres du
gouvernement mesdames et messieurs les
députés chers collègues
avant d'appeler l'examen des questions
gouvernement je voudrais évoquer avec
vous la mémoire de Madame
Marsa à minuit
c'était le 16 septembre dernier en Iran
brutalement arrêté au nom d'une supposée
vertue pour une simple mèche de cheveux
qui dépassait de son voile elle est
décédée
depuis des femmes des hommes et toute la
jeunesse d'Iran dont il faut admirer
l'incroyable courage exprime leur soif
de liberté
[Applaudissements]
alors que le nombre de la des victimes
de la répression auquel ils sont
confrontés et chaque jour un peu plus
important la représentation nationale
unanime nous en avons discuté ce matin
en conférence des présidents souhaitent
rendre hommage à ces femmes et à ses
hommes qui depuis le 16 septembre paix
de leur vie leur combat pour la liberté
la première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les membres du gouvernement
mesdames et messieurs les députés chers
collègues je vous demande de bien
vouloir respecter une minute de silence
je vous remercie
donc l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions gouvernement la première
question va être posée par madame la
Présidente Le Pen
merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre madame la Première
ministre il y a quelques jours votre
Ministre de l'économie nous a expliqué
que le budget de la France était à
l'euro près c'était juste avant ces
conseils vestimentaires pour passer
l'hiver conseils qui ont fait florès
dans votre gouvernement entre doudoune
col roulé même pyjama alors je ne vais
sûrement pas me lancer dans cette
infantilisation de nos compatriotes mais
ma question concerne les Français qui
sont à l'euro près et ils sont nombreux
et qui se demandent comment ils vont se
chauffer cet hiver vous obstinez à ne
pas vouloir rompre avec les règles
absurdes du marché européen de
l'électricité qui maintient les prix
élevés pris qui sera payé par les
français via leur facture et via leurs
impôts vous obstinez à ne pas baisser la
TVA sur les produits énergétiques comme
l'ont fait d'ailleurs certains de nos
voisins
vous envisagez de céder du gaz à
l’allemagne tout en expliquant aux
Français qu'il faudra faire des efforts
bref tout cela n'a ni que ni tête mais
quand l'idéologie prend le pas sur le
pragmatique on arrive à de tels
aberrations alors permettez-moi de vous
interroger aujourd'hui sur la situation
des millions de compatriotes qui se
chauffent au fioul et qui sont en ce
moment même en train de remplir leur
cuve en juillet dernier suite à la
mobilisation de notre groupe nous avons
voté contre la vie du gouvernement une
enveloppe de 230 millions pour les
soutenir et depuis à part l'annonce
d'une future aide aucune nouvelle et
surtout aucun calendrier ce n'est pas
dans un mois voire plus que les gens ont
besoin de cette aide c'est maintenant
vous ne le savez peut-être pas mais ça
coûte plus cher de faire deux
demi-plains de cuve à fioul qu'un plat
or pour ce plat ils ont besoin de
l'argent que vos oppositions leur ont
octroyé
divisez les 230 millions votés par le
nombre d'utilisateurs de chaudières à
fuel que vous souhaitez aider ne me
semble pas bien compliqué alors pourquoi
le décret d'application de cette mesure
n'a pas encore été pris qu'attendez-vous
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
merci Madame l'après-midi
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la Présidente Le Pen alors je voudrais
tout d'abord le rappeler
l'explosion de l'énergie c'est avant
tout la conséquence de l'agression de
l'Ukraine par la Russie
j'ai pris 100 vols parce que la Russie a
décidé de réduire considérablement
l'approvisionnement en gaz de l'Europe
cette hausse est renforcée par la faible
disponibilité de notre part s'il vous
plaît face à cela notre stratégie et
globale et cohérente
protégez et préparer l'avenir
protéger les Français c'est d'abord
faire en sorte que nous puissions passer
l'hiver sans coupure c'est ce que nous
faisons en ayant anticipé cette
situation délétée en portant l'obstacle
en portant nos stocks au niveau de gaz
au niveau maximum en diversifiant nos
approvisionnements en augmentant les
capacités de nos terminaux métaniers
c'est ce que nous faisons avec le plan
sobriété qui est un sujet sérieux madame
la Présidente nous le présenterons dans
les prochains jours il mobilise l'État
les collectivités les entreprises et nos
concitoyens et c'est ce que nous ferons
grâce à la solidarité
européenne nous livrerons du gaz à nos
voisins qui nous livreront en retour de
l'électricité
ne vous en déplaisse madame la
Présidente c'est à l'échelle européenne
que nous assurons notre sécurité
d'approvisionnement et que nous pourrons
maîtriser les prix de l'énergie
car protéger les Françaises c'est aussi
agir contre la hausse des prix c'est le
bout le but des boucliers tarifaire sur
le gaz et l'électricité qui empêche les
prix de doubler c'est la mesure la plus
protectrice d'Europe cela mérite d'être
rappelé mais bien sûr nous agissons pour
tous les Français y compris ce qui se
chauffent au fioul et sont souvent parmi
les plus précaires vous l'avez dit le
Parlement a voté cet été une enveloppe
de 230 millions d'euros destinés à aider
ceux qui sont en train de remplir
actuellement leur cuve et je vous
confirme que ces Français recevront bien
une aide et il bénéficieront même
il recevront dans les prochaines
semaines une aide et il bénéficieront en
outre d'un chèque énergie exceptionnelle
pour affronter la hausse des prix et au
total c'est jusqu'à 400 euros dont
pourront bénéficier les Français les
plus modestes pour payer leur facture de
fioul
et je précise madame la Présidente nous
protégeons tous les Français face à
cette situation d'urgence mais nous
préparons aussi l'avenir l'avenir c'est
une société décarbonée c'est notre
souveraineté énergétique et grâce à ma
prime rénove nous accompagnons les
Français qui changent leur chaudière
floues et plus largement pour assurer
notre souveraineté énergétique nous
tablons sur le nucléaire et les énergies
renouvelables donc votre assemblée est
saisi d'un projet de loi sur les
énergies renouvelables et vous serez
prochainement saisis d'un projet pour
accélérer nos projets d'énergie
nucléaire je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la Première
ministre
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à madame la Présidente
berger
merci madame la Présidente pour Méline
tout a commencé par ce qu'elle appelle
une petite gifle puis les coups ont
continué un coup de poing puis deux
quand mon compagnon rentrait avec un
problème de travail c'est moi qui
prenais le soir on reste pour les
enfants on se dit que c'est pas possible
que ça va pas recommencer
Alexandra elle est restée 29 ans avec
son bourreau au bout de la première
année pour elle aussi ça a commencé par
une gifle après c'était des coups de
poing des coups de bottes j'ai été
défigurée alors moi je le dis aux femmes
dès que vous recevez une gifle allez
porter plainte il ne faut pas avoir peur
même des fois par amour on veut pas le
faire mais il y a des institutions des
associations des personnes qui sont là
pour nous aider depuis plusieurs
semaines on loue la vertu de celui qui
reconnaît des faits de violences
conjugales
depuis plusieurs semaines on entend ce
qui parle de leur affection pour un
homme qui frappe sa femme depuis
plusieurs semaines on fait fi des règles
élémentaires de l'État de droit on jette
le discrédit sur les femmes et les
hommes policiers et gendarmes qui au
périls de leur vie interviennent après
des signalements violences conjugales on
jette le discrédit sur l'institution
judiciaire on jette en fait des dizaines
d'années de combat nos associations qui
ont permis aux victimes d'être
accompagnés par la seule voie qui peut
mettre un terme à leur souffrance la
voie judiciaire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît mes
chers collègues Saint-Laurent berger à
la parole s'il vous plaît
je crois que ce sujet appelle le calme
et non le trouble ou le désordre je
crois que ce sujet mérite mieux que des
esclandre et je suis navré que vous
reconnaissiez si bien dans les propos
que j'ai exprimé
est-ce que tout fonctionne aujourd'hui
madame la Première ministre la réponse
est non mais est-ce que des progrès ont
été accomplis la réponse c'est oui le
conjoint violent doit quitté le domicile
nos policiers gendarmes et magistrats
sont formés les dépôts de plainte sont
facilités jusque dans nos hôpitaux les
téléphones graves dangers sont déployés
alors oui oui nous devons faire mieux et
ça commence par nos attitudes ça
commence par les mots que nous employons
simplement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la parole
est à madame la Première ministre qui
seule à la parole
madame le Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la
Présidente Aurore berger
il y a 20 ans jour pour jour une femme
de 17 ans soit Benziane était brûlée
vive elle est devenue un des plus
tragiques symboles des violences faites
aux femmes et je veux avoir une pensée
pour elle pour sa famille pour toutes
les femmes victimes de violence
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
et la grande cause des quinquennats
d'Emmanuel Macron nous avons agi dans
tous les domaines nous avons agi aussi
avec force contre toutes les formes de
violence sexistes et sexuelles et je
sais madame la Présidente Aurore berger
votre engagement personnel pour ce
combat et je veux le saluer avec le
Grenelle des violences conjugales nous
avons obtenu de nombreux avancées pour
que la parole se libère et que chaque
victime puisse être prise en charge nous
avons étendu les horaires du 39 19 mis
en place une plateforme de signalement
en ligne favoriser la prise de plainte
et lancer la création d'un fichier des
mises en cause s'il vous plaît mes chers
dans cette hémicycle puisse écouter
votre réponse vous on nous avons 28
questions au Gouvernement vous aurez
largement le temps de vous exprimer je
vous prie d'arrêter d'invectiver les
orateurs quels qu'ils soient
c'est en effet un sujet sérieux et je
voudrais continuer à vous préciser les
actions qui ont été engagées depuis 2017
madame
[Applaudissements]
au donc pour le traitement des plaintes
pour mieux protéger les victimes nous
avons formé près de 160 000 policiers et
gendarmes déployés des téléphones graves
danger et des bracelets anti
rapprochement mais tant qu'il y aura des
coups nous continuerons dix mille places
d'hébergement seront ouvertes dès cette
année j'ai annoncé le mois dernier
l'ouverture de 1000 places
supplémentaires en 2023 nous allons
doubler la présence policière dans la
rue nous voulons améliorer notre réponse
et nos procédures pénales et je viens de
confier à votre collègue Emilie Chandler
et à la sénatrice Dominique Verrien une
mission parlementaire en ce sens et je
le rappelle vous l'avez dit madame la
Présidente berger en ces domaines seul
institution judiciaire peut déterminer
les faits dire le droit et sanctionner
la lutte contre les violences conjugales
est un combat fondamental j'y tiens le
gouvernement continuera à le mener avec
force avec les associations avec des
élus avec toutes celles et tous ceux qui
veulent s'engager je vous remercie je
vous remercie madame la Première
ministre
madame
au Bono je vous précise qu'en
application de l'article 71 du règlement
je prononce un rappel à l'ordre à votre
rencontre
[Applaudissements]
alors
vous continuez à invectiver l'assemblée
et à activer la présidence si c'est ce
que vous faites
donc je prononce un rappel à l'ordre
avec inscription procès-verbal
alors la prochaine question au
gouvernement va être posée par Madame
Clémentine Autain pour le groupe la
France insoumise
alors que rien n'y oblige pourquoi
voulez-vous nous voler nos plus belles
années de retraite le porte-parole du
gouvernement nous a prévenu repousser
l'âge de départ à 65 ans se fera quel
que soit la méthode qu'importe la
démocratie pour vous que vous ayez
l'ivresse de détruire nos droits pour
maintenir le marché libre et les hyper
riches bien au chaud par la force vous
voulez imposer une immense régression
sociale à la majorité de notre pays au
mépris de tout au mépris des conclusions
du Conseil d'orientation des retraites
non le système n'est pas en déficit il
est même excédentaire avec une
trajectoire maîtrisée jusqu'en 2070 au
mépris du taux de chômage croissant des
seniors qui devraient décourager toute
idée d'allonger le temps dans l'emploi
au mépris des femmes et des précaires
qui seraient les premières victimes d'un
allongement de la durée de cotisation au
mépris de l'opposition massive dans le
pays plus de 7 Français sur 10 rejettent
votre idée d'un nouveau recul de l'âge
de départ à la retraite non travailler
plus longtemps ne sera jamais jamais un
progrès pas plus qu'a baisser le niveau
des pensions notre système a permis de
réduire la pauvreté chez les retraités
alors pourquoi vouloir le démolir vous
prétendez dégager ainsi 8 milliards pour
payer nos hôpitaux et nos écoles mais
vous oubliez de décompter les
répercussions en termes de chômage de
santé et de solidarité et si vous
cherchez de l'argent ce n'est pas
compliqué d'en trouver 8 milliards c'est
ce que nous coûterait la suppression des
impôts de production que vous prévoyez
on peut aussi trouver 10 milliards avec
la taxe sur les super profits c'est tout
simplement un choix de société et c'est
pourquoi nous appelons à une grande
marche à Paris le dimanche 16 octobre
pour faire entendre la voix de cette
majorité cette majorité qui refuse
l'érosion sans fin de nos droits à la
retraite madame la Première ministre
pourquoi refusez vous de l'entendre
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier du
chope ministre du travail et du plein
emploi
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
autant vous nous affirmez doctement que
le système de retraite ne serait pas en
déficit le rapport du Conseil
d'orientation des retraites organismes
indépendant du gouvernement dit
effectivement qu'en 2022 le système sera
légèrement excédentaire d'un peu plus de
3 milliards d'euros il dit qu'en 2023 il
sera déficié d'un milliard 8 il dit
qu'en 2027 demain à la fin du
quinquennat le déficit c'est 12
milliards et demi d'euros par an c'est
20 milliards en 2030 c'est 40 milliards
en 2040 et ce sont des hypothèses qui
sont faites sur une base de chômage à
5%, c'est-à-dire le plein emploi la
réalité c'est que notre système n'est
pas équilibré et que lorsqu'on y tient
on le modernise pour qu'il puisse durer
la position qui est la vôtre votre appel
au statu quo votre conservatisme en
réalité votre position c'est la position
qui fera baisser les retraites vous êtes
le camp de l'appauvrissement des
retraités et le temps qui veut priver
nos enfants donne droit à la retraite
nous sommes le temps de la respons des
pensions minimales à 1100 euros de la
prise en compte de la pénibilité et de
la garantie de la plus grande solidarité
celle pour les générations qui viennent
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à monsieur le Président
Marleix
elle marche pas
[Rires]
on censure des oppositions merci madame
la présidente Madame Le Pen ayant rendu
hommage au combat des députés des
républicains sur le prix du fioul je
voudrais madame le Premier ministre vous
interrogez sur le prix de l'électricité
pour les entrepreneurs français la
France produit de l'électricité
nucléaire notamment à 50 euros le
mégawattheure et pourtant nos
entreprises doivent actuellement se
fournir avec des contrats à 600 700
euros le mégawattheure pourquoi à cause
d'un marché européen devenu totalement
absurde qui lit le prix de l'électricité
et le prix du gaz monsieur Poutine a
créé une crise du gaz en Europe l'Europe
s'est inventée une crise de
l'électricité
la situation est aujourd'hui intenable
pour la plupart de nos entreprises on
voit avec ces boulangeries qui ferment
en ce moment par dizaines tous ces
artisans qui nous disent qu'ils ne
passeront pas l'hiver et puis ces
entreprises industrielles qui sont
conduites à arrêter purement et
simplement leurs production après trois
années de crise cette situation crée de
véritables drames et situation de
détresse humaine or aujourd'hui les
mécanismes de protection qu'ils soient
nationaux ou qu'il soit européen je
pense aux décisions du dernier conseil
de vendredi dernier seront quasiment
inopérantes en France et en tout cas
très largement insuffisante on est très
loin des 200 milliards que le
gouvernement allemand va donner à ces
entrepreneurs pourtant il y a des pays
qui s'en sortent je pense à l'Espagne au
Portugal ou le prix de l'électricité est
inférieur à 200 euros parce qu'ils ont
réussi à faire reconnaître une exception
ibérique pourquoi ce qui est possible en
Espagne ne l'est pas en France parce que
me répondrez-vous grâce à la pitoyable
gestion du parc nucléaire la France est
devenue aujourd'hui un mendiant
énergétique mais nous produisons encore
80% de notre électricité et cette
électricité ne vaut pas Madame le
Premier ministre 500 euros de
mégawattheure qu'attendez-vous pour
prendre des mesures d'urgence pour nos
entreprises merci beaucoup la parole est
à madame la Première ministre merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
Président marlex alors je peux vous
assurer mon gouvernement est totalement
mobilisé pour protéger les Français les
entreprises et les collectivités face à
la flambée des prix de l'énergie
nous avons d'abord agi pour protéger les
Français avec la prolongation des
boucliers tarifaires en 2023 un je
rappelle que ces boucliers il
permettront de limiter à 15% la hausse
des prix du gaz et de l'électricité pour
les ménages au lieu d'une hausse de
120%, je précise que ce bouclier il
bénéficie au ménage mais aussi au Très
Petites Entreprises et à la plupart des
communes qui peuvent bénéficier des
tarifs réglementés de l'électricité mais
nous voulons en effet agir pour protéger
également les entreprises et les
collectivités et vous avez raison il
s'agit pour cela de traiter le problème
à la racine en faisant baisser le prix
de l'électricité sur les marchés
européens vous l'avez dit les Espagnols
ont réussi à diviser par trois les prix
de l'électricité c'est ce mécanisme que
nous voulons étendre à toute l'Europe
des avancées ont été réalisés lors du
dernier conseil énergie le président de
la République s'entretient cette semaine
avec la présidente de la commission et
avec le chancelier allemand avant le
conseil de vendredi et nous avons
vraiment de bonnes raisons de penser que
nous pourrons faire aboutir ce mécanisme
mais en tout état de cause nous
préparons également un filet de sécurité
pour aider les entreprises et les
collectivités les plus en difficulté
donc pour les entreprises il s'agit tout
d'abord d'améliorer le soutien pour
celles qui consomment beaucoup d'énergie
qui a été mis en place mais qui doit
être améliorée le ministre de l'Économie
y travaille et par ailleurs Bruno Le
Maire et Agnès panier renacher recevront
demain les fournisseurs d'énergie pour
leur demander aussi de bien refléter ces
prix vous l'avez dit il bénéficie
d’arène nous souhaitons retrouver ce
tarif privilégié de l'arène dans les
prix proposés aux entreprises et aux
collectivités et puis pour les
collectivités je le rappelle à nous
avons voté dès cet été dans le cadre du
projet de loi de finances rectificative
un dispositif pour protéger les
collectivités les plus fragiles je pense
que c'est du reste un exemple
des compromis que nous pouvons trouver
ensemble nous travaillons à améliorer ce
dispositif pour qu'il réponde bien à
toutes les situations et puis je le
redis à au-delà de ces situations
d'urgence nous devons renforcer notre
souveraineté énergétique c'est l'objet
du projet de loi pour accélérer le
développement des énergies renouvelables
dont votre assemblée se rapprochement
saisie et également du projet de loi
pour accélérer le renouvellement de
notre parc nucléaire dont vous serez
prochainement saisi je vous remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Mounir
belamitié pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Intérieur
depuis plusieurs semaines plusieurs mois
Nantes et le théâtre d'agression et de
violences de nature diverses autant de
faits graves qui n'abîme pas seulement
l'image de la ville il pourrissent
littéralement la vie des habitants la
municipalité nantaise après avoir tenté
de minimiser la réalité on appelle
désormais à l'état de la vie même des
syndicats de policiers municipaux la
ville ne tient pas ses propres
engagements en matière de sécurité mais
la mère de Nantes dénonce aujourd'hui un
déficit de moyens de police et de
justice monsieur le ministre les Nantais
n'y comprennent plus rien
pouvez-vous nous indiquer monsieur le
ministre quels ont été les évolutions
des moyens de la police mais aussi de la
justice ces dernières années à Nantes et
quels sont les avancées que le projet de
budget 2023 de ces deux ministères
permettra de dégager pour le pays et
plus spécifiquement pour la sécurité des
antennes je vous remercie je vous
remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
comme vous j'ai constaté depuis
plusieurs mois désormais une
augmentation de la violence dans
l'agglomération nantaise singulièrement
dans Nantes et dans son centre ville
cette augmentation de violence est
d'autant plus
étonnante que dans les autres grandes
villes de France depuis plusieurs
semaines et j'aurai l'occasion d'en
parler très bientôt nous voyons une
baisse très importante parfois à deux
chiffres des violences faites aux
personnes et au bien mais dans
l'agglomération nantaise cette violence
continue les faits divers
particulièrement
ignoble montre effectivement
l'étendue des difficultés que connaît
l'agglomération nantaises vous me
demandez de comparer ce qui est
comparable il y a eu à Nantes 132
augmentations d'effectif de police
nationale passant de 677 policiers à 809
policiers dans le quinquennat précédent
dont 70 rien que la dernière année
en revanche nous pouvons constater
qu'effectivement si on prend des villes
comparables Montpellier par exemple
quand il y a 339 caméras de vidéos à
Montpellier il y en a que 145 à Nantes
et lorsqu'il y a 182 policiers municipal
à Montpellier il y en a 126 à Nantes
j'ai pris mon Montpellier pour qu'on ne
puisse voir effectivement la même
couleur politique évidemment avec un
même nombre de population je recevrai ma
valeur de Nantes après les questions au
Gouvernement je veux l'assurer que nous
trouverons ensemble je l'espère les
moyens d'assurer la sécurité de
l'agglomération nantaise on
l'encourageant à mettre davantage de
caméra de vidéoprotection en embauchant
davantage encore de policiers municipaux
et avec la première ministre nous avons
décidé pour 2023 l'arrivée d'une unité
de d'une unité de CRS de 200 effectifs
supplémentaires à Nantes j'espère que
ceux qui crie voteront les budgets du
ministère de la police dans quelques
jours
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
monsieur bel-amitié
merci monsieur le ministre pour ces
éléments factuels et chiffrés
effectivement le vote du budget 2023
donnera l'occasion à notre assemblée de
concrétiser vos propositions en matière
d'augmentation moyen de police et de
justice nous verrons qui seront au
rendez-vous merci
je vous remercie la parole est au
président Valo pour le groupe socialiste
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre nous avons appris hier
que le garde des sceaux mis en examen
depuis juillet 2021 était renvoyé devant
la Cour de Justice de la République il a
fait un pourvoir en cassation en 2017 le
candidat Emmanuel Macron aujourd'hui
président affirmé que tout ministre mis
en examen devrait démissionner je
voudrais savoir ce que vous pensez
aujourd'hui de cette déclaration
je vous remercie
madame la Première ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Boris Vallot alors j'ai pris acte de la
décision rendue hier dans le cadre de la
procédure engagée contre Eric
Dupond-Moretti devant la Cour de Justice
de la République et voyez-vous je ne
crois pas qu'il soit démocratiquement
sain que des décisions de l'autorité
judiciaire soit commentée ici dans
l'enceinte du pouvoir législatif par un
membre de l'exécutif
et je le rappelle l'indépendance de
l'institution judiciaire est un principe
cardinal de notre démocratie la
présomption d'innocence en est un autre
pilier j'ai pleinement confiance dans
notre démocratie et dans notre justice
je vous remercie présidente s'il vous
plaît
madame la Première ministre je vois
poindre et peut-être vous avec moi un
conflit d'intérêt dans quelques mois
l'actuel procure générale près de la
Cour de cassation prendra sa retraite et
le président de la République lui
donnera un successeur sur avis du garde
des sceaux ici judiciaires
il y aura deux difficultés madame la
Première ministre d'abord ce nouveau
procureur général aura à connaître
probablement du pourvoi en cassation du
garde des sceaux il aura s'il était
décidé d'un renvoi devant la Cour de
Justice de la République à connaître de
l'affaire qui occupera à nouveau le
garde des sceaux juste iciable dans
quelle démocratie peut-on d'une certaine
manière participer au choix de ses
magistrats je vous pose la question dans
un souci je pense partager
d'indépendance de la justice de respect
de tous les droits y compris ceux de la
défense et j'y vois aussi une condition
de présomption d'innocence
je vous remercie
madame madame la Première ministre alors
pour répondre à votre question d'une
part je voudrais noter que contrairement
à ce que certains peuvent soutenir le
garde des sceaux n'est pas empêché le
ministère de la justice fonctionne il
est pleinement engagé il avance il se
transforme il voit ses moyens renforcés
à un niveau inédit il se déploie sur
l'enjeu de sécurité de justice du
quotidien pardon et il participe
pleinement à la mobilisation de mon
gouvernement
contre la délinquance mais par ailleurs
je vous précise également qu'un
dispositif de déport a été mis en place
ce principe est simple il n'y a aucune
interférence il n'y aura aucune
interférence dans le suivi des dossiers
dans lesquels le Garde des Sceaux est
impliqué soit en tant que justiciable
soit dans ce dont il aurait pu connaître
en tant qu'avocat ce dispositif est
exigeant il me conduit à piloter
directement une série de sujets et vous
aurez certainement pu constater dans les
dernières semaines que seul l'intérêt
général et l'exigence d'impartialité
guide les décisions du gouvernement je
vous remercie
je vous remercie madame la Première
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Sébastien Jumel pour le groupe GDR
madame la Première ministre en l'absence
de majorité à l'Assemblée nationale pour
faire passer d'autorité votre projet de
réforme des retraites le président de la
République brandit la menace de la
dissolution
ce droit constitutionnel existe donc
actes mais devant l'opposition
majoritaire des Français qui ont compris
depuis longtemps que le recul de l'âge
de la retraite est injuste parce que
nous n'avons pas tous les mêmes points
de vie en bonne santé le président de la
République ne peut pas n'a pas le
pouvoir de dissoudre le peuple
dans un contexte où la guerre sans
Christ en Europe où l'on volait des prix
là des régulations du marché de
l'énergie font mal aux vies font mal à
l'économie réelle le groupe communiste
et républicains vous fait la proposition
solennelle suivante de faire trancher
cette importante question par le peuple
un outil simple est à notre disposition
la motion référendaire et je vous
annonce que nous allons l'utiliser
58 députés suffisent pour soumettre à
l'Assemblée tout entière le recours à la
souveraineté populaire par voie de
référendum madame la Première ministre
qu'il y a 77 ans jour pour jour dans le
sang les larmes et l'espérance de la
Libération la France se dotée de son
régime de sécurité sociale aujourd'hui
puisque le président de la République
lui-même n'a pas exclu le recours au
référendum pouvez-vous vous engager à
consulter le peuple français
sur ce qui est au cœur de notre modèle
de protection sociale à la française le
système des retraites
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier du stop le ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Député Jumet je dois d'abord
reconnaître au groupe communiste le
mérite de la constance en 2020 vous avez
déjà proposé que cette réforme des
retraites soit soumise à référendum nous
n'avons pas fait ce choix nous n'avons
pas fait ce choix là nous avons fait un
choix différent ce choix c'est à la fois
pour le président de la République de
porter le débat pendant la campagne
présidentielle et qu'on vous conviendrez
avec moi que en annonçant pendant la
campagne présidentielle que nous
envisions d'augmenter progressivement
l'âge de départ à la retraite d'abord à
64 puis à 65 ans le risque politique
pris était majeur et qu'il donne une
forme de légitimité même si j'entends
vous ne la partagez pas totalement nous
avons fait un deuxième choix deuxième ce
deuxième choix celui de la concertation
il a aussi peut-être qu'on viendrez-vous
avec moi que la concertation n'a pas
commencé en 2022 cela fait des années
désormais que les questions de
pénibilité d'emploi des seniors
d'équilibre du régime de prise en compte
de la précarité
des sujets qui sont soumis à la
concertation et sur lesquels nous
travaillons nous avons décidé sur
l'autorité de madame la Première
ministre d'ouvrir un dernier cycle de
concertation dès demain l'ensemble des
organisations syndicales participant au
Conseil d'orientation des retraites
l'ensemble des organisations
d'employeurs participants au Conseil
d'orientation des retraites moins
indiqué qu'elles seront présentes à la
première rute réunion multilatérale de
concertation que j'organise sur le sujet
de la réforme des retraites nous allons
ouvrir des sites de concertation pour
que d'ici à la fin de l'année nous ayons
à la fois une réforme un ensemble de
décisions que nous puissions trouver le
maximum de compromis et je sais très
bien tous les désaccords ne sont pas
faciles voire impossible à surmonter
avec un objectif ultime c'est de
proposer au Parlement et il y aura un
débat politique démocratique cette
réforme des retraites pendant l'hiver
pour qu'elle soit applicables au cours
de l'été 2023 nous avons un objectif
sauver le système par répartition
garantir sa soutenabilité ça durabilité
l'améliorer avec de meilleures pensions
avec une meilleure prise en compte de la
pénibilité et avec une meilleure prise
en compte des carrières hachées
d'objectifs sur lesquels nous pouvons
nous retrouver
je vous remercie monsieur jumelles il ne
m'a pas échappé monsieur le ministre en
2020 en pleine crise vous avez actionné
le 49-3 mais il a dû vous échapper que
l'assemblée d'aujourd'hui n'est plus
l'armée de Playmobil d'hier et que nous
avons des conditions politiques pour
mettre à consultation le peuple français
sur une question de cette importance
la parole est à Madame Louise Morel pour
le groupe démocrate
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à Bruno Le Maire
ministre de l'économie des finances et
de la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique monsieur le ministre tout
d'abord je tiens à saluer au nom du
groupe démocrate l'action du
gouvernement face à cette crise
énergétique d'une ampleur exceptionnelle
c'est au total plus de 53 milliards
d'euros que l'État a engagé pour
protéger les Français via le bouclier
tarifaire sur les prix du gaz et de
l'électricité mais également avec le
chèque énergie de 100 euros dont près de
6 millions de foyers sont bénéficiaires
ou encore par les mesures de soutien des
ménages se chauffant au fioul sans ces
mesures la facture des Français aurait
augmenté de plusieurs centaines d'euros
par mois en revanche pour les
professionnels si des dispositifs
d'accompagnement sont prévus les
critères d'accès à ces aides sont
vraisemblablement trop restrictifs
partout sur nos circonscriptions des
artisans des chefs d'entreprise et
d'industrie
alors le critère du coût de l'énergie
fixé à 3% du chiffre d'affaires mais
d'autres critères restent également
fortement l'accès aux aides le critère
du doublement du prix de l'énergie sur
la période concernée ou encore celui de
l'excédent brut d'exploitation qui doit
être négatif face à cette situation les
entreprises n'ont que peu d'options soit
elle répercutent les coûts sur leur prix
de vente et donc sur le portefeuille des
Français quitte à prendre le risque de
perdre une partie de leurs clientèle ou
alors elle baisse leur marge pour
supporter elle-même ses coûts mais
combien de temps cela peut-il durer ma
question est la suivante monsieur le
ministre que comptez-vous mettre en
place pour permettre à nos entreprises
de passer l'hiver un assouplissement des
critères d'accès aux aides est-il prévu
je terminerai ce propos en soulignant
que notre action collective a permis à
nombre d'entreprises de surmonter la
crise sanitaire soutenons-les
aujourd'hui plus que jamais pour que
cette nouvelle crise n'est pas raison
d'elle je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Roland Lescure ministre chargé
de l'Industrie madame madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la député Louise Morel
merci pour votre question qui rejoint un
certain nombre d'interpellations de vos
collègues sur tous les banques qui nous
interpellent régulièrement sur le fait
que oui les entreprises aujourd'hui font
face à des hausses extrêmement
importantes du prix de l'énergie auquel
nous devons faire face et sur lesquels
nous devons agir commencez peut-être par
excuser la l'absence de Bruno Le Maire
qui justement est à Luxembourg
aujourd'hui dans le cadre d'un conseil
écofine pour négocier les paramètres des
aides d'État qui nous permettront à la
fois d'amplifier et de simplifier le
plan de soutien aux entreprises dites
energo intensives qui vous l'avez dit
aujourd'hui sont trop restreints et nous
empêchent de rejoindre finalement les
entreprises qui en ont réellement besoin
le gouvernement avait déjà mis en place
un certain nombre de mesures depuis un
an avec de l'avance y compris pour les
entreprises mais il faut reconnaître que
la hausse des prix cet été la forteuse
de la volatilité à renforcer les
contraintes
avec Olivia Grégoire de manière à ce que
eux aussi fasse une partie des efforts
pour soutiennent l'industrie les
donneurs d'ordre doivent en faire autant
les distributeurs doivent en faire
autant nous les avons réuni avec Marc
feno pour que l'industrie
agroalimentaire ne soit pas une victime
merci
la parole est à Monsieur Emmanuel bléri
pour le groupe rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur
Emmanuel Macron à la volonté d'accélérer
la répartition des migrants dans nos
villages c'est immigration c'est celle
qui sature nos villes et dont vous les
déverser le trop-plein dans nos
campagnes c'est aussi ce signal clair en
voyant vague migratoire prête à déferler
la France est à vous mais la France
n'est pas un hôtel c'est la maison des
Français le peuple doit pouvoir décider
ou quand comment pour qui et combien de
temps il fait preuve d'hospitalité 22
000 communes 2 sur 3 on fait le choix de
Marine Le Pen au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle
nous et de la nation nous les voyons et
nous les entendons ces élus locaux que
vous méprisez tant re a besoin de
médecins Hayette a besoin de transport
public que au Mesnil a besoin de
subvention pour rénover son église et
dont les maires des petites communes se
sont eux les véritables Mozarts de la
finance du quotidien nos villages
nos villages ont besoin de plus de
services publics de plus d'emploi et de
plus d'écoles non monsieur le ministre
la ruralité n'a pas besoin de plus de
migrants ce n'est pas seulement
l'Assemblée nationale que vous souhaitez
dissoudre c'est le pays tout entier les
Français doivent savoir que leurs élus
rassemblement national font et feront
tout pour empêcher cette folie nous
pensons que c'est le peuple qui doit
trancher il y a un seul moyen et vous le
connaissez le référendum vous le refusez
aujourd'hui nous le ferons demain alors
monsieur le ministre vous qui avez fait
le lien entre immigration et insécurité
allez-vous écouter l'immense majorité
des Français et protéger notre douce
France cher pays de notre enfance merci
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Sonia bac S
secrétaire d'État en charge de la
citoyenneté
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Emmanuel bléri le président de la
République est le ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer l'ont
répété notre politique migratoire doit
évoluer pour cela nous devrons être nous
devons être plus durs avec ceux qui
n'ont pas vocation à rester sur le sol
français et faire plus d'efforts avec
ceux qui ont vocation à y rester pour
qu'il s'intègre mieux dans la société
française
qu'ils y partagent notre langue nos
valeurs nos règles nos lois ainsi
l'intégration des étrangers en situation
régulière est un enjeu majeur de notre
politique migratoire nous en sommes
conscients le système actuel qui conduit
à une concentration anormale dans
certains territoires dans certains
quartiers n'est pas satisfaisant
est-il soutenable que 50% des demandeurs
d'asile se présente en Île-de-France là
où précisément tous les dispositifs de
prise en charge sont totalement saturés
à l'évidence non nous devons donc mieux
répartir pour mieux intégrer les enfants
des étrangers en situation régulière
seront les Français demain nous devons
tout faire pour qu'ils partagent notre
langue nos valeurs nos lois qu'ils
intègrent nos entreprises quand elles
ont besoin de main d'oeuvre au demeurant
ce mécanisme existe déjà il fonctionne
et il a fait ses preuves pour les
demandeurs d'asile et nous l'avons testé
à grande échelle avec l'accueil des
personnes déplacées d'Ukraine une grande
partie a afflué en quelques jours à
Paris à Strasbourg à Nice une fois
l'accueil d'urgence garantie nous leur
avons proposé d'être hébergé partout sur
le territoire et cela a fonctionné de la
même façon les déplacer Ukrainiens
accueillis depuis la Moldavie ont été
directement orientés en
nouvelle-aquitaine et cela a fonctionné
la France n'aurait pas été en capacité
d'accueillir correctement ces personnes
si nous les avions maintenu à Paris en
Île-de-France tous vos aborder
métropoles dans ces quartiers qui
souffrent déjà de nombreuses difficultés
économiques et sociales ce mécanisme il
nous faut aujourd'hui le développer les
tendres au plus grand nombre notamment à
travers des mécanismes incitatifs c'est
l'intérêt monsieur le député de tous les
Français c'est le travail que nous
conduisons en concertation avec les
territoires madame la ministre
monsieur Blairy
oui madame ministre justement au sujet
des Ukrainiens sachez une chose les
villes qui ont reçu des Ukrainiens ont
reçu 0 centime voilà je voulais vous le
soigner madame
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Sabrina c'est bailli pour le groupe
écologiste merci madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre il aura
fallu attendre la guerre en Ukraine pour
vous entendre enfin aborder les termes
de sobriété et d'économie d'énergie
alors que la loi climat est résilient
c'était terriblement éloignée des
recommandations de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat que de temps
perdu à nous traiter d'amish alors que
nous parlions déjà de sobriété à
l'époque alors que les prix flambes nous
avons le droit à un véritable défilé de
mode de votre gouvernement ministre à
bord en Arbor en col roulé au doudoune
en pleine semaine de la Fashion Week je
suis au regret de vous l'apprendre mais
vous n'êtes pas sur un podium vous êtes
responsabilité de ce pays madame la
Première ministre ceux qui ont froid ne
portent pas de col roulés ceux qui ont
froid accumulent les couches de
vêtements et de couverture celles et
ceux qui ont froid se massent dans les
450 000 logements considérés comme
indigne ils sont les 2, 3 millions de
personnes en attente de logements social
sur cette question votre projet de loi
finance 2023 n'est pas à la hauteur des
défis d'abord parce que les bailleurs
sont dépourvus des structurels pour
massifier le parc et assurer la
rénovation énergétique ils sont comme le
service public abandonnés ensuite parce
que les mesures telles que le bouclier
tarifaire sont trop faibles et de court
terme dans ma circonscription à Suresnes
des locataires assistent déjà
impuissants à des coupures d'énergie
dans leur logement faute d'avoir pu
payer leurs factures qu'allez-vous
répondre aux collectivités locales déjà
saignées par la baisse drastique de leur
dotation qu'allez-vous répondre aux
écoles et aux universités l'université
de Nanterre connaît une augmentation de
sa facture énergétique de 600%, vos
décisions mettent en danger la
continuité du service public des
hôpitaux des collectivités des écoles et
j'en passe madame la Première ministre
vous coupe vous pouvez couper le
chauffage chez vous mais beaucoup de
Français ne vont pas l'allumer
d'aussitôt et ce n'est pas par choix le
vrai courage de déclarer l'état
d'urgence énergétique et de prendre les
mesures pour les millions de Français
qui vivent dans la précarité énergétique
la parole est à Monsieur Christophe
Béchu ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre
madame la députée
l'urgence climatique elle est là elle
nécessite que la sobriété ne se soit pas
que le mot d'ordre pour l'hiver qui
arrive
quand vous accusez ce gouvernement
d'inaction sur le front de la lutte
contre la crise énergétique vous tapez à
côté notre pays est celui qui a engagé
les sommes les plus importantes pour
faire en sorte de protéger les Français
le bouclier est tarifaire qui a été mis
en place et qui vaut pour la totalité
des ménages qui vaut également pour les
offices HLM et qui couvrent le
dépassement des factures quant ailleurs
en Angleterre au Pays-Bas en Allemagne
on a multiplié par deux par trois par
quatre le montant de la facture
énergétique des autres Européens
témoignent de la réalité de cet effort
vous pointez les besoins qui
existeraient pour les collectivités
locales pour les administrations et pour
les entreprises la première ministre a
eu l'occasion il y a quelques minutes de
préciser que notre première effort sur
le plan européen il est d'obtenir la
réforme du marché de l'électricité le
découplage du système qui consiste à
calculer le prix de l'électricité sur le
gaz pour faire en sorte de baisser les
tarifs et pour ne pas couvrir avec des
boucliers tarifaires les rentes d'un
certain engager une énergéticien qui
seront reçues demain à la fois par Agnès
panière une hachée et par Bruno Le Maire
en ce qui concerne l'effort en direction
des entreprises et des collectivités
locales baisser les tarifs pour obtenir
que nous n'ayons pas à rembourser des
sommes indus c'est le premier étage le
deuxième c'est la contribution sur la
rente le troisième c'est la rénovation
publique des bâtiments au delà des
efforts qui ont été faits dans le cadre
du plan de relance nous travaillons cet
automne pour préciser les mécanismes qui
permettront d'assurer une rénovation
thermique aussi bien des bâtiments de
l'État des collectivités territoriales
avec un objectif conjugué la nécessité
de passer cet hiver et de nous inscrire
dans l'atténuation de l'urgence
climatique
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à monsieur Adrien Gomis pour
le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Madame la Ministre de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
comme vous l'avez rappelé madame la
Présidente le 16 septembre dernier est
décédé Massa à mini à la suite de son
arrestation par la police des mœurs
chargée entre guillemets de préserver
l'ordre moral à savoir notamment le port
obligatoire du voile par les femmes dans
la sphère publique si le port
obligatoire du voile est ciblée
aujourd'hui ce qui est à l'origine de la
contestation populaire c'est le régime
d'emola
la protestation partout dans le pays de
la mer Caspienne au golf persique
démontre la capacité de la société
civile iranienne à s'opposer
courageusement au péril de sa vie à
l'intégrisme religieux érigée en
politique d'État
c'est d'ailleurs depuis plus de 4
décennies que les Iraniennes sont les
principales victimes de ce totalitarisme
religieux et malgré son destin funèbre
Massa Amini est devenu la figurine qui
incarne la liberté l'égalité et l'unité
d'un peuple
issu d'une civilisation multi millénaire
malgré les tentatives de coupure de
l'Internet les censures les images
terribles nous parviennent ici en Europe
face à cette répression violente par
l'appareil sécuritaire iranien plus de
100 morts d'après certains chiffres les
pays occidentaux ont pris diverses
mesures je tiens et notre groupe tient
également à saluer leur mémoire et
apporter tout notre soutien à ces femmes
et ces hommes qui se battent
une question madame la ministre et vous
avez condamné courageusement ces
nouvelles atteintes massives au droit
des femmes et aux droits de l'homme en
Iran vous annoncez examiner avec nos
partenaires européens les options
possibles
pouvez-vous nous en dire plus et plus
globalement qu'envisagez-vous de faire
pour d'un côté condamner le régime et de
l'autre soutenir les Iraniennes et les
Iraniens dans ce combat je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Catherine Colonna
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
députés
madame le Président tout d'abord merci
d'avoir commencé cette séance par une
minute de silence à la mémoire des
victimes de la répression en Iran
les manifestations qui ont suivi la mort
de Macha Amini ont été et sont toujours
la cible d'une répression violente qui a
déjà fait des dizaines et des dizaines
de morts
alors la France a condamné dès le 19
septembre avec la plus grande fermeté
les violences qui ont entraîné la mort
choquante de cette jeune femme et la
violence qui est utilisée et continue de
l'être contre les manifestants nous
avons appelé les autorités iraniennes au
respect du droit manifesté pacifiquement
au respect du droit au rassemblement et
aussi au respect de l'exercice de leur
métier par les journalistes j'ai
moi-même rappelé ces principes
fondamentaux à plusieurs reprises à New
York aussitôt à Paris à Marseille alors
l'Iran a considéré qu'il s'agissait là
d'une ingérence que de rappeler les
principes fondamentaux des droits de
l'homme et il a cru bon de le faire
savoir à notre ambassade sur place
j'ai donc décidé de faire convoquer le
chargé d'affaires iranien à Paris il n'y
a pas en ce moment d'ambassadeurs pour
exiger la fin de la répression aveugle
et dire clairement ce que nous pensons
des méthodes iraniennes il a été reçu
vendredi 30 septembre au Quai d'Orsay
au fond qu'est-ce qui se joue dans les
rues des villes d'Iran la liberté la
répression est brutale nous connaît donc
dans les termes les plus forts cette
répression aveugle menée contre des
femmes et des hommes qui respectent
leur dignité telle qu'il soit
la liberté à localisation aspire et
cette aspiration à la liberté elle est
désormais visible elle est dans les rues
elle est dans les universités elle est
dans les cœurs les femmes diront demande
à être libre nous les soutenons et nous
continuerons les soutenir nous avons
engagé monsieur le député au-delà des
sanctions qui déjà frappent ce pays
depuis de longues années un travail au
sein de l'Union européenne pour
poursuivre un certain nombre d'options
envers les tenants du régime qui
envoient les manifestants à la mort et
qui envoient souvent leur ressortissants
et leurs enfants dans nos pays cela ne
peut pas durer nous devons les
sanctionner et nous le ferons en
concertation avec
la parole est à Monsieur Hugo bernalicis
pour le groupe la France insoumise
madame la Première ministre une question
se pose
quels sont les points communs entre les
affaires Alexis color secrétaire général
de l'Élysée et l'affaire Eric
Dupont-Moretti garde des sceaux ministre
de la justice
[Rires]
je vous remercie
[Musique]
Monsieur Olivier du
parole du gouvernement
mais ici c'est le Parlement on est
sérieux je vous laisse poser votre
question j'y répondrai avec plaisir
juste après
[Applaudissements]
oui je sens une gêne et un petit
flottement sur les bancs du gouvernement
et c'est normal
il y a deux points communs le premier
c'est l'incrimination la prise illégale
d'intérêt si une infraction particulière
car c'est la situation de pouvoir de ces
deux personnes qui ont permis la
réalisation de l'infraction l'un pour
favoriser sa famille à la tête du
croisieriste MSC l'autre pour interférer
dans des affaires judiciaires en cours
sur fond de règlement de compte
personnel et c'est aussi un problème
politique et pas seulement judiciaire
car en restant en poste ils peuvent à
nouveau commettre les mêmes délits
d'atteinte à la probité desquels ils
sont accusés le deuxième point commun
n'est nul autre que le monarque
présidentiel Emmanuel Macron lui-même
lui aussi responsable pénalement mais
pas ses proches qu'il couvre désormais
révélant une confusion des fonctions et
une dérive mafieuse du pouvoir quel
scandale jamais un garde des Saône
avait en procès devant la Cour de
Justice de la République tout en étant
encore en fonction jamais un secrétaire
général de l'Élysée n'avait été mis en
examen alors que le président en
exercice lui-même avait versé au dossier
judiciaire un document pour dédouaner
son subordonné pourtant en 2017 le
candidat Macron faisait de son
engagement en politique une promesse de
changement dans les pratiques une
promesse de tourner la page du temps où
l'on pouvait en toute impunité utiliser
les moyens de l'état des fins privés le
Macron de 2022 président des riches se
révèle être un oligarque mêlé aux
intérêts financiers ce n'est plus
Jupiter c'est le parrain
40 à faire judiciaires ont été recensés
depuis 2017 concernant la macronie alors
les Françaises et les Français qui vont
se mobiliser pour la marche contre la
vie chère et l'inaction climatique du 16
octobre prochain à Paris ils veulent
savoir madame la Première ministre
est-ce que vous les amis d'Emmanuel
Macron est là pour servir ou pour vous
servir
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier Véran
porte-parole du gouvernement
[Applaudissements]
et ça me fait penser un adage que je
vais adapter pour vous quand on a pour
soi la justice insoumise celle des
hommes est devenu
inutile voilà ce qui m'inspire à votre
question la France insoumise c'est le
régime de la mise en examen et la
condamnation permanente Monsieur Le
Buteur enfin condamnation pour les
autres bien sûr condamnation pour les
autres j'avais le Parlement il y a
quelques années à changer le mot prévenu
pour mise en examen parce qu'on trouvait
que mise en examen ça permettait bien de
démontrer qu'aucune décision n'avait
rendu mais que la justice allait se
pencher avec sérieux sur un dossier pour
déterminer s'il y avait ou non une
responsabilité c'est par exemple la
différence monsieur le député importante
avec la condamnation la condamnation
c'est par exemple celle de Monsieur
Mélenchon lorsqu'il a été condamné par
le tribunal de Bobigny de façon
définitive en décembre 2019 pour avoir
pour avoir je cite pour avoir je cite
fait pression acte de rébellion en
réunion provocation acte d'intimidation
on a dépositaire de l'autorité publique
et envers un magistrat à l'époque vous
en souvenez monsieur député il était
député à côté de vous il était même
votre président de groupe il était même
quelques mois plus tard votre candidat à
la présidentielle et quelques semaines
plus tard votre candidat chef de fil à
la lupinte pour les législatives c'est
donc la différence fondamentale entre
mise en examen et condamnation je vous
le redis je pensais naïvement en réalité
monsieur le député j'ai pas envie de
crier c'est le début c'est la rentrée je
pensais naïvement que les dernières
affaires qui ont touché directement vos
collègues ou certains de vos amis
avaient pu vous conduire à davantage de
retenue je le regrette j'avais tort
monsieur député je vous propose une
hygiène collective où vérin vous verrez
ça vous mettra parfois moins dans
l'embarras également de votre côté en
deux points 1 on laisse la justice faire
son travail en deux on ne commande pas
une affaire de justice en cours vous
verrez ça ira mieux et à la fin c'est
collectivement qu'on y gagnera parce que
à chaque fois que vous jetez le prof sur
la classe politique vous le faites vous
reculez aussi dans l'opinion publique et
vous participez de couper le lien
précieux qui reste entre les citoyens et
leurs élus vous êtes élu je suis élu
vous n'êtes pas juges je ne suis pas
juge laissons les travailler c'est
simple
je vous remercie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
[Musique]
la parole est à Monsieur Franck Giletti
pour le groupe rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente la question
s'adresse au ministre des Armées lancé
en 2017 par la France et l'Allemagne
puis rejoint par l'Espagne voilà
maintenant un an que le programme SCAF
dont l'issue de parvenir au
développement d'un système de combat
aérien du futur reste au point mort or
nous semblons perdre de vue le fait
qu'au-delà du nécessaire convergence de
doctrine une coopération a pour premier
objectif de servir les armées et non de
répondre à l'idée d'une Europe de la
défense fantasmée par un président de la
République dont il est pourtant le seul
arrivé en outre vous devriez savoir
qu'une coopération ne peut fonctionner
qu'en ayant identifié un maître d'œuvre
compétent à ce stade le désaccord de me
rendre Dassault et la filiale allemande
d'Airbus quand on partage des tâches sur
la furtivité et les commandes de vol
semblent encore une fois nous distinguer
de nos voisins allemands
à l'heure où la guerre frappe de nouveau
le seul européen je crois nécessaire de
rappeler que l'on ne fait la guerre
correctement qu'avec les matériels qu'on
a conçus soi-même coopérer c'est d'abord
garantir son indépendance c'est pourquoi
le rassemblement national se pose
fermement à ce projet chimérique qui
remet en cause notre souveraineté en
tant que rapporteur pour avis du budget
de l'armée de l'Air et de l'Espace cette
question me préoccupe particulièrement
notamment parce que vous avez affirmé
très récemment que le SCAF était un
projet prioritaire et assuré de son
aboutissement or en juin dernier dans un
rapport consacré au programme d'armement
le ministère allemand de la Défense
évoquait la possibilité d'abandonner le
programme si aucun compromis n'était
trouvé cette divergence de discours me
semble pour le moins révélatrice de nos
désaccords doctrino monsieur le ministre
dans un tel contexte géopolitique cette
enlisement n'est-il pas révélateur de la
nécessité pour la France de s'affirmer
en tant que puissance autonome par le
développement d'une politique
diplomatique et militaire n'est-ce pas
là Monsieur le Ministre un argument
suffisant pour qu'enfin on va donner à
notre BITD les moyens de fournir à notre
armée un avion de combat aérien du futur
qui nous soit propre la France
devra-t-elle encore se soumettre cette
fois-ci militairement aux exigences d'un
voisin troporilleux ou comme le propose
le rassemblement national réaffirmé sa
souveraineté en quittant définitivement
le programme SCAF jouant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
députés Giletti la première des choses
déjà c'est que si on peut imaginer ce
type de coopération c'est précisément
parce que domestiquement ici en France
nous sommes bons on le doit à Airbus on
le doit
au succès du Rafale sur lequel parfois
trop souvent certaines familles
politiques ont mis en doute notre
capacité jadis à exporter le Rafale et
aujourd'hui c'est le cas donc c'est
coopérations franco-allemande elles sont
possibles elles sont permise aussi parce
que la France est chef de fil et
d'assaut et chef de fil sur le projet du
SCAF la deuxième des choses c'est que le
SCAF ce n'est pas qu'un avion c'est
aussi le système de drone qui va autour
de l'avion ce sont aussi les systèmes de
Cloud qui permettent de connecter
l'avion à son environnement collaboratif
là soyons clairs si on le fait tout seul
ça coûtera plus cher ou ça prendra plus
longtemps que si nous faisons en
coopération après regardons les choses
avec beaucoup de tranquillité les
coopérations doivent être toujours
gagnant-gagnante il doit y avoir plus
d'avant que d'inconvénients à conduire
cette opérations donc c'est assez simple
et le chancelier et le président de la
République en ont discuté hier au soir à
Berlin je l'ai dit à mon homologue à 15
jours également à Berlin nous devons
regarder le calendrier avec beaucoup de
fermeté car il s'agit d'affirmer
l'autonomie stratégique française car
nous avons besoin d'un avion de chasse
pour le futur pour notre dissuasion
nucléaire pour notre autonomie et il est
vrai monsieur le député que quand on
interroge nos alliances on dit toujours
un peu qui on est et que nous préférons
les alliances européennes que
désignement sur Moscou ou ailleurs
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Madame Marie-Agnès poussié
20 bac pour le groupe horizon
madame la Présidente Mesdames messieurs
les ministres chers collègues ma
question s'adresse s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre depuis quelques jours
nous pouvons lire ici ou là des articles
sur la bonne santé des collectivités
bien loin de moi l'idée de contester les
montants annoncés je veux toutefois
aujourd'hui vous alerter sur la
situation des villes moyennes qui
disposent de nombreux équipements
publics portent depuis toujours des
charges de centralité très importante
exerce sur leur contribuable une
pression fiscale déjà conséquente et
vont se retrouver pour certaines face à
un mur d'ici la fin de l'année
madame la Première ministre certaines
collectivités sont étranglées par des
charges qui étaient imprévisibles
certaines collectivités sont étranglées
par des factures d'énergie bien
supérieures à celles qui étaient
prévisibles lors des préparations
budgétaires certaines collectivités sont
étranglées par l'augmentation importante
des coûts
de restaurants scolaires certaines
collectivités sont étranglées par une
augmentation du point d'indice de leurs
agents que nous avons décidé cet été
même si elles sont convaincus que
celles-ci était absolument indispensable
certaines collectivités sont enfin
débordées par des demandes émanant de
leur centre communaux d'action sociale
mère d'une ville centre et présidente
d'agglomération jusqu'à il y a quelques
semaines j'ai pu mesurer à quel point
les communes rurales n'étaient pas en
reste
l'épargne éventuelle dont ces communes
disposeraient seraient destinées à des
projets d'investissement prévus souvent
de longues dates la journée de ces
projets inquiète évidemment les élus nos
concitoyens mais également terriblement
les entreprises du bâtiment et des
travaux publics alors madame la Première
ministre après un premier geste sur la
DGF ma question est simple comment
envisagez-vous d'aider ces communes qui
sont vraiment vraiment en situation
compliquée et ne savent comment
construire leur budget à venir merci
beaucoup je vous remercie la parole est
à Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre madame la députée poussiézbach
vous l'avez dit un rapport de la Cour
des comptes décrit une photographie de
la situation des collectivités
territoriales qui est sans équivoque sur
le fait que la situation des
collectivités s'est améliorée au cours
du dernier quinquennat puisque ce que
pointe la Cour des comptes c'est la
comparaison de l'épargne en fin de
quinquennat par rapport au début et de
l'ensemble des fondamentaux et des
dépôts au trésors mais l'année 2022 elle
ne ressemble pas l'année 2021 elle a été
marquée par la guerre en Ukraine elle a
été marquée par la poussée de
l'inflation elle a été marquée par la
progression des prix de l'énergie face à
ça le gouvernement a déjà agi en
relevant le niveau de l'arène en faisant
en sorte de supprimer la tessiefe qui
permet 400 millions d'euros d'économies
pour les collectivités territoriales en
validant et un accompagnant un
dispositif dans le cadre du PLF de 430
millions d'euros dont les décrets sera
présenté d'application sera présentée
demain au Comité des finances locales
qui a été l'oeuvre collective des
parlementaires et du gouvernement pour
arriver un dispositif de soutien
exceptionnel et nous arrivons à l'aube
de ce budget 2023 pour la première fois
depuis 13 ans
le gouvernement a décidé de majorer
l'enveloppe de DGF qui vous est
présentée ça n'était pas arrivé depuis
2010 nous avons dans le même temps à la
fois conserver un bouclier tarifaire qui
je veux le rappeler concerne 28 000 des
35 000 communes de ce pays qui bénéficie
du tarif réglementé pour toutes les
communes de moins de 10 salariés et de
moins de 2 millions d'euros de recettes
reste celle que vous avez évoqué les
villes moyennes les grandes villes dans
le prolongement de certaines questions
qui ont eu lieu aussi pour les
entreprises plus importantes en taille
la stratégie elle se décline en trois
étapes obtenir comme ça déjà été dit une
réforme du marché de l'électricité
européenne qui évite qu'on se retrouve à
devoir payer une rente à cause du
couplage gaz électricité faire en sorte
de regarder comment nous pouvons
continuer à déployer un filet de
sécurité le rapporteur général de budget
à imaginer et présenter un dispositif et
nous ne laisserons pas les collectivités
sur le bord du chemin face à cette
dérive enfin nous sommes en ce moment en
train de travailler de manière précise y
compris à l'échelle européenne pour
améliorer ce dispositif global de
couverture merci Monsieur le Ministre la
parole est à Madame Raquel Garrido pour
le groupe la France insoumise
c'est un chant qui s'est répandu à
travers
l'iranatar SIM Natar SIM Mohamed
cela veut dire n'ayons pas peur n'ayant
pas peur nous sommes ensemble ce slogan
a été repris par les courageux femmes
iraniennes qui manifestent au péril de
leur vie
défiant les autorités
politico-réligieuses et le régime des
mots là
ce slogan s'adresse d'abord aux autres
femmes iraniennes mais il raisonne
aujourd'hui comme un mot d'ordre
international de la révolution féministe
vous n'êtes pas seuls rejoignez-nous
après la mort de Massa à Nini tué par la
police des mœurs vous l'avez rappelé
madame la Présidente pour un voile mal
porté les iraniennes ont chanté n'ayant
pas peur nous sommes ensemble après la
répression brutale ayant menée à la mort
de plus de 92 personnes les Iraniennes
sont redescendus dans la rue pour clamer
n'ayant pas peur nous sommes ensemble et
hier encore des lycéens ont bravé
l'interdit pour chanter en cœur dans
leurs écoles n'ayant pas peur nous
sommes ensemble quel courage ces mots
sont entendus par toutes les femmes en
France et dans le monde qui subissent la
pression la domination le patriarcat la
misogynie parce que ce sont des femmes
chers collègues
que des travées de cette assemblée cœur
battant de la démocratie française
s'entend notre message aux iraniennes au
nom de la République française au nom
des idéaux d'égalité de liberté de
sororité que nous portons n'ayez pas
peur nous sommes ensemble depuis deux
semaines en France à solarité de la
solidarité s'exprime deux dimanches
durant des manifestations ont eu lieu
j'y étais nous y étions madame la
Première ministre j'ai pu observer lors
de la manifestation du 25 septembre un
usage disproportionné de la force je
pense notamment à l'usage de gaz
lacrymogène contre des manifestants
devant l'ambassade d'Iran manifestants
dans la cause on est tous d'accord et
noble alors ma question est simple
pouvons-nous pouvez-vous madame première
ministre garantir désormais que ces
manifestations
je vous remercie ma chère collègues
alors madame
Catherine Colonna ministre de l'Europe
et des Affaires étrangères
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Garrido j'avoue ne pas savoir quelle
question à répondre puisque madame
Garrido n'a pas souhaité poser sa
question
[Musique]
j'ai rappelé madame la députée la
gravité des faits qui se déroule en Iran
et nous appelle tous à la dignité
cette séance a commencé dans la dignité
le sujet mérite qu'elle continue dans la
dignité madame la députée j'ai rappelé
donc la gravité des faits j'ai dit notre
condamnation
j'ai dit le travail que nous avons
engagé pour des sanctions s'ajoutant aux
actuels sanctions j'ai dit nos soutien
aux femmes iraniennes et à celles et
ceux qui les appuis parce que oui
enlever son voile couper ses cheveux
sortir dans la rue manifestée alors que
des dizaines et des dizaines de
personnes ont déjà été victimes de la
répression défier la police des mœurs ce
sont autant d'actes de courage autant
d'actes de courage
accompli individuellement
puis par centaines par milliers alors
nous ne pouvons pas nous taire et nous
devons saluer le courage
des femmes et des hommes qui aujourd'hui
manifestent en Iran c'est ce que je fais
devant la représentation nationale à
laquelle je dis notre admiration notre
respect et notre soutien et Madame la
député si je puis de comparer que ce qui
est comparable les violences en Iran et
la protection d'une emprise diplomatique
non rien à voir ne faites pas de
comparaison absurde indigne à nouveau
ridicule et qui n'a pas lieu d'être
merci
je vous remercie
[Musique]
la parole est à Monsieur Laurent Fany
pousse
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre
l'agriculture au ministre la transition
écologique et à madame la secrétaire
d'État à la ruralité l'été 2022 a été
dévastateur pour notre agriculture les
températures élevées qui ont sévit dans
tout le pays on fait suite à un
anniversaire
les conséquences de la sécheresse ont
été particulièrement lourdes pour le
monde agricole le département de
l'Ariège cher à mon cœur n'échappe pas
ce triste constat les pertes annoncées
et atteignent près de 60% pour le
tournesol la situation de l'élevage est
également préoccupante avec 30 à 50% de
perte les éleveurs sont contraints de
recourir à la fourragement précoce à
l'importation de fourrage à
l'acquisition à l'acquisition de
compléments alimentaires
par ailleurs les tensions
internationales provoquent une hausse
importante des diverses charges des
exploitations qui voient leur situation
financière fortement dégradée
les éleveurs d'Ariège et d'ailleurs
commencent à décapitaliser leur cheptel
c'est-à-dire vendre leur outil de
travail pour passer l'hiver c'est un
signal d'alerte monsieur le ministre
dans ces circonstances et pour faire
face à ses nombreuses pertes que ce soit
pour les éleveurs les céréaliers les
aboriculteurs ou les maraîchers il est
donc impératif de soutenir l'agriculture
en mobilisant tous les leviers
disponibles et notamment en débloquant
une aide d'urgence et directe afin de
soutenir les différentes filières pas
une avance pas un après remboursable nos
agriculteurs demandent des actes forts
et rapides à la mesure de leur désarroi
nous devons soutenir notre modèle
agricole pour ne pas glisser vers une
perte massive de notre souveraineté
alimentaire
en ce jour d'ouverture du Sommet de
l'élevage à Clermont-Ferrand pouvez-vous
nous indiquer monsieur le ministre quel
soutien le gouvernement compte mettre en
place pour accompagner le monde André
agricole en souffrance je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Christophe
Béchu ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion de
territoires
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre monsieur le député panifouz
vous comprendrez évidemment pour les
raisons que vous venez d'évoquer
l'absence de Marc feno
qui précisément est au contact des
éleveurs vous avez eu raison de rappeler
la sécheresse exceptionnelle que nous
avons vécue qui se conjugue avec les
difficultés liées à la situation
géopolitique et avec les tensions que ça
que ça provoque effectivement sur ce qui
permet de nourrir les élevages un mot
très rapide pour vous dire que cette
sécheresse elle a donné lieu à Marseille
je dis de la semaine dernière au
lancement du premier chantier de
planification écologique en présence
d'un représentant du ministère de
l'Agriculture d'Agnès Firma lomodo de
Bérengère Couillard pour que nous
puissions lancer à la fois le retour
d'expérience de ce que nous avons vécu
mais aussi la brique qui va nous
permettre de sécuriser l'eau potable
quand on a constaté que plus d'une
centaine de communes en a été privée de
limiter les fuites de regarder comment
on peut mieux réutiliser les eaux usées
et de nous préoccuper précisément des
prélèvements dans l'agriculture a besoin
avec la perspective d'aller vers des
types et des modèles d'agriculture qui
soient moins consommateurs en eau pour
être capable de tenir
qui n'est pas lié qu'à une année
particulièrement faible en termes de
pluviométrie mais qui plus largement il
y a un réchauffement climatique qui va
multiplier ce type de crise donc vous
avez raison sur le fait que nous ne
devons répondre dans l'urgence face à
cette situation et c'est très exactement
ce que le ministère de l'agriculture et
la souveraineté alimentaire est en train
de faire et de discuter avec le monde
agricole pour les raisons que vous avez
indiqué parce que ce qui est en jeu
c'est notre souveraineté c'est notre
capacité à pouvoir nourrir les habitants
de ce pays avec des circuits courts et
en faisant en sorte d'éviter d'importer
au maximum les produits dont nous avons
besoin parce que c'est à la fois bon
pour la planète et bon pour la défense
de notre économie mais dans le même
temps nous devons avoir un regard
au-delà et ce seront les actions
concrètes que nous annoncerons en fin
d'année dans le cadre de la feuille de
route de planification écologique sur le
fait d'accompagner la totalité de notre
économie vers ce grand défi
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Madame Christelle
d'Internet pour le groupe les
républicains
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
madame la Première ministre aujourd'hui
les Français sont les mieux protégés
tels sont les propos de votre Ministre
de l'économie dans l'hebdomadaire
challenge le 29 septembre dernier et là
la réalité que vit les Français au
quotidien est bien éloigné de ces
éléments de langage feutré la réalité
des Français madame la Première ministre
c'est notamment les lourdes difficultés
que connaissent les artisans boulangers
les chiffres sont là 85% d'augmentation
sur le prix de la farine en un an 15%
d'augmentation rien contre septembre et
octobre 215% d'augmentation sur le kilo
de beurre le prix de l'huile a quant à
lui quadruplé cette flambée des prix que
nous connaissons et continue
exponentielle incontrôlée et dans bien
des cas injustifiés cette semaine en une
nuit le kilo de beurre a augmenté de
28%. les artisans boulangers sont
étranglés par le prix des matières
premières et pour le coup de l'énergie
certains en sont au point de supprimer
la fournée de l'après-midi pour ne pas
avoir à rallumer leur four et au bout de
la chaîne ce sont les Français qui
paient l'addition la baguette passe de 1
euro à un euro 30 et les boulangeries
qui ne peuvent pas suivre son contrainte
de fermer mettant fin parfois au seul
commerce de proximité en territoire
rural les artisans boulangers ne sont
qu'un exemple parmi tant d'autres la
réalité qui est dénoncée par les
boulangers comme Frédéric III à Nice par
des industriels comme Thierry Dalbéra
dans ma circonscription mais aussi la
grande distribution comme Michel-Edouard
Leclerc c'est que cette inflation qui
tue aux entreprises et en plus
considérablement le pouvoir d'achat des
Français n'est bien souvent pas justifié
la guerre en Ukraine n'explique pas tout
les artisans les commerçants les
Français ont besoin de réponses
concrètes et d'action et je ne parle pas
de leur proposer de porter des cols
rouler
alors ma question est la suivante
quelles sont les conclusions de
l'enquête sur la hausse des prix des
légendées par Bercy en juillet dernier
et que comptez-vous faire pour mettre
fin à la spéculation afin de protéger
merci beaucoup la parole est à Madame
Olivia Grégoire ministre délégué chargé
des petites et moyennes entreprises du
commerce de l'artisanat et du tourisme
merci madame la présidente madame la
députée d'une Torny oui je confirme les
propos de Bruno Le Maire et de madame la
Première ministre même situation la
situation est difficile les Français
sont tout de même mieux protégés que
nombre de nos compatriotes l'inflation
lycée sur un an c'est 5,8% l'inflation
dans les prix alimentaires c'est
7,7%. oui il y a une inflation plus
forte sur les produits alimentaires
c'est pourquoi nous travaillons
d'arrache-pied et sans relâche à la fois
pour protéger nos producteurs nos
agriculteurs mais aussi pour protéger
nos consommateurs je suis aussi en
charge de la consommation et aussi nos
artisans je connais bien le boulanger
auquel vous faites référence et je vous
remercie d'ailleurs d'avoir pris le
temps d'interroger sur cette profession
qui est inquiète et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je les recevrai après de
nombreux échanges le 18 octobre prochain
pour continuer à avancer je veux
rappeler grâce à votre question madame
gintorni et vous le savez que nombre de
nous boulangers bien sûr souffre on est
en train de travailler avec Roland
Lescure et marcéno pour trouver un
mécanisme européen et mieux les protéger
mais nos TPE les boulangers sont souvent
des TPE vous le savez sont protégés
parce qu'on appelle le TRV TPE 1,5
millions de nos TPE bénéficient d'une
sorte de bouclier tarifaire du même
acabit que celui qui protège les
Français les ménages et donc même si nos
boulangers souffrent je veux dire à quel
point il est important qu'ils appellent
leurs fournisseurs d'énergie pour voir
s'ils sont éligibles au trvt TPE ça peut
paraître technique c'est pas un élément
de langage mais ça protège nos artisans
et plus d'un million et demi d'entre eux
est-ce qu'il faut faire plus très
certainement c'est ce que madame la
Première ministre vient de rappeler il y
a quelques minutes et quelques minutes
pardon et c'est pour ça que nous
continuons à travailler avec Bruno Le
Maire avec Roland Lescure et vous savez
avec marfeno vous parlez grande
distribution je veux être complète
toutes les semaines nous animons le
comité de suivi des relations
commerciales et Gallim et Gallim 2
toutes les semaines nous appelons à la
responsabilité la grande distribution
une partie prend ses responsabilités
nous sommes
merci madame la ministre
la parole est à Madame Anne Laurence
Petel pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre des
Affaires étrangères et j'y associe mes
collègues engagés auprès de l'Arménie
madame la ministre je veux vous parler
d'une guerre dont personne ne parle
aussi peu je veux vous parler de
l'Arménie envahie par l'Azerbaïdjan le
13 septembre dernier l'Arménie dont les
frontières souveraines et
internationalement reconnus ont été
violées l'Arménie victime d'une
véritable guerre de conquête aujourd'hui
50 km² de son territoire sont déjà
occupés par Bakou qui sait où s'arrêtera
il améliev ce despote sans foi ni loi
qui a lancé ses troupes à l'assaut du
sud de l'Arménie deux ans après la
guerre du haut Karaba et qui porte avec
Erdogan le paon Turquie un projet de
réunion des peuples turcophones dans un
empire où le peuple arménien n'a pas sa
place le régime azzeri multiplie les
exactions il torture mutilent à bout
portant des soldats prisonniers
l'épreuve sont là personne ne pourra
dire qu'il ne savait pas
madame la ministre il ne s'agit pas
seulement d'un crime choquant il s'agit
de crimes de guerre Bakou ne devra pas
uniquement en répondre mais être
poursuivi pour cela en 1915 les
Arméniens étaient victimes du 1er
génocide du 20e siècle en 2022 les
rollands macabre de l'histoire ont à
nouveau les Arméniens ils font face à
une menace existentielle pas moins je
veux saluer ici l'engagement du
président de la République qui a reçu le
premier ministre Nicole pachignon à
l'Élysée la France se trouve sans
ambiguïté aux côtés de l'Arménie l'Union
européenne doit en faire autant quand
madame vanderleyenne plaisante aux côtés
de monsieur aliès nous lui disons que
les vies arméniennes valent mieux que
tous les accords commerciaux alors
madame la ministre ma question est
double comment la France entend soutenir
plus fortement l’arménie et comment
comptez-vous obtenir la mise en place
d'une force d'interposition
internationale les Arméniens ont le
droit de vivre en paix et en sécurité
je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Catherine Colonna ministre de l'Europe
et des Affaires étrangères
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
petelle je comprends votre indignation
et je la partage comme tous ici dans
cette hémicycle qu'il s'agisse de la
représentation nationale ou des membres
du gouvernement
oui l'exécution de prisonniers de guerre
est une violation du droit international
humanitaire est constituent
un crime de guerre il ne peut pas y
avoir d'impunité dans de tels cas
la France est solidaire du peuple
arménien je le redis sans ambiguïté elle
a donc appelé au lancement immédiat
d'une enquête
impartiale et indépendante pour
identifier les auteurs de ses actes et
pour assurer qu'il puisse être traduit
en justice et là aussi je le précise
appeler à la libération immédiate de
l'ensemble des prisonniers Arméniens
encore détenues et je renouvelle
aujourd'hui cet appel
sur le fond du conflit les incursions
armées récentes de l'Azerbaïdjan en
Arménie sont extrêmement graves le
président de la République a pris
contact aussitôt avec ses homologues
Arméniens et zarbanjanais pour appeler à
l'arrêt des combats au respect de
l'intégrité territoriale de l'Arménie et
un retrait des positions
occupées par l'Azerbaïdjan j'ai fait de
même nous avons également saisi le
Conseil de sécurité qui a tenu deux
réunions les 15 et 16 septembre
ces événements qui se sont déroulés sur
le territoire internationalement reconnu
de l'Arménie ont aussi révélé je le
souligne l'incapacité de la Russie a
joué le rôle d'arbitre qu'elle avait
prétendu être la seule à pouvoir assumer
suite aux affrontements de l'année 2020
alors la France continue à agir pour un
règlement pacifique et négocié de cette
crise notamment vient en ce moment c'est
l'axe de nos efforts la mise en place
d'une mission d'établissements des faits
de l'OSCE l'Organisation pour la
sécurité et la coopération en Europe je
me suis entretenu il y a quelques jours
à peine avec le président d'exercice de
l'ESCE mon collègue polonais merci
Madame la Ministre la parole est à
Madame Fatia kello hachis pour le groupe
socialiste
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à la ministre de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
femmes vie liberté
voici ce que résonne depuis plusieurs
jours dans les rues de Téhéran Shiraz et
disparant et partout ailleurs en Iran
plus qu'un slogan c'est un cri un appel
puissant courageux pour une liberté pour
la liberté depuis trop d'années bafoué
femme je veux aujourd'hui rendre hommage
à toutes ces femmes ces jeunes
iraniennes rejoindre désormais par de
nombreux jeunes Iraniens qui bravent la
mort et manifestent chaque soir contre
l'oppression d'un système en place ces
femmes qui chaque jour
au travers de leur combat réaffirme leur
soif d'émancipation vie c'est ce que la
police des mœurs saôter le 16 septembre
dernier à Marsa à mini iranienne de 22
ans pour les quelques cheveux qui
dépassaient de son voile depuis ce sont
des dizaines de femmes qui ont connu le
même sort
liberté c'est ce que demande les
Iraniennes à travers leurs mouvements la
liberté de disposer de leur corps de
porter les vêtements qu'elle seule
trouve approprié et de pouvoir enfin se
sentir libre au travers du port ou du
non-port du voile selon leur propre
volonté
le 21 septembre 2022 seulement 5 jours
après la mort de Marsa amine le
président de la République s'affichait
officiellement aux deux côtés d'Ibrahim
raïti tête du régime iranien et
responsable de la répression en cours
alors ma question je vous demande madame
la ministre avec ce choix politique quel
est le message que le gouvernement
envoie au reste du monde et surtout quel
envoie au peuple iranien
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Catherine Colonna ministre de l'Europe
et des Affaires étrangères merci madame
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs des
députés madame la députés kélouachi
le nom de Macha minite connu désormais
dans le monde entier en effet et depuis
son décès le mot de liberté est
également sur toutes les lèvres en Iran
alors nous avons condamné sa mort
condamné les violences condamnées la
répression je l'ai dit je le redis et
votre question madame la députée m'offre
aussi l'occasion de revenir sur l'action
de la France au sein de l'Union
européenne depuis
ces événements actions je le disais d'un
mot tout à l'heure qui vise à répondre à
la répression en ciblant les
responsables de celle-ci en les tenants
pour responsables de leurs actes
ne vous y trompez pas de telles mesures
peuvent avoir un impact sur les
décisions les décideurs pardon du régime
en Iran alors que il s'applique à
réprimer d'un côté ils envoient de
l'autre nombre d'entre eux en tout cas
leurs enfants vivrent en Occident il
s'agira de geler leurs avoir et je les
droits à voyager voici ce qui est en
cours
vous m'interrogez par ailleurs mesdames
sur les contacts que la France
entretient avec ce pays qui est l'Iran y
compris au niveau du président de la
République et du président iranien
permettez-moi de rappeler que cet
entretien qui a eu lieu en marge de
l'Assemblée générale des Nations unies à
New York a permis d'évoquer des sujets
importants et graves il s'agit d'une
part de faire revenir l'Iran au respect
des garanties qu'elle doit à l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie atomique au
titre du traité qu'elle a signé et qui
ne sont pas respectés il s'agit d'autre
part lors de cet entretien d'appeler
l'Iran à réfléchir une dernière fois
avant de ne pas accepter l'accord sur le
jpco et comme on l'appelle c'est à dire
permettre le retour à un accord visant à
éviter que l'Iran atteigne le seuil
nucléaire c'est l'intérêt de tous enfin
Madame la Députée le président n'a pas
manqué de rappeler ce que nous pensons
du régime mernien des privations de
liberté qui sont y compris y compris
celles qui sont faites un nombre ne
ressortissants dont il a demandé la
libération immédiate nous avons quatre
ressortissants sur place la ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Jean-Victor castor
pour le groupe golf démocrate et
républicaine merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à Monsieur
Darmanin ministre de l'intérieur de
l'outre-mer
monsieur le ministre lors de votre
voyage en Guyane vous avez fait des
annonces essentiellement axées vers le
trafic de drogue il est vrai que la
drogue transit par la Guyane pour
arriver en hexagone et on peut dès lors
comprendre l'urgence qu'il y a pour vous
d'empêcher ses arrivées quotidiennes
mais la sécurité en Guyane c'est aussi
l'empaillage illégal le pillage des
ressources halieutiques le trafic
d'armes la prostitution l'habitat
spontané et insalubre la non
surveillance des frontières la sécurité
en Guyane est économique elle est
environnementale elle est sociale elle
est judiciaire et elle est sanitaire
pour vous il y a urgence d'empêcher
l'arrivée de la drogue en hexagone pour
les Guyanais l'urgence est que la drogue
n'arrive pas à en Guyane l'urgence a que
les réseaux de trafic divers soit
totalement démantelé
mais avec des milliers d'enfants non
scolarisés et 53% de la population
vivant sous le seuil de pauvreté on ne
propose à la jeunesse que les trafic la
prison ou l'exode
tant qu'il y aura en Guyane une négation
systémique des droits tant qu'il
manquera des structures de soins et
d'éducation tant qu'il manquera des
routes tant que la population sera
entravée par des lois et des interdits
tant que l'État confisquera 90% des
terres il y aura de l'insécurité les
mesures que vous portez tant à répondre
à une urgence mais ne mettrons pas fin à
toutes ces insécurités monsieur le
ministre vous vous êtes engagé à ouvrir
un dialogue sur la restitution des
terres c'est un préalable au
développement endogène et le
développement économique est un
préalable à la sécurité publique
êtes-vous prêt à utiliser immédiatement
ce levier exclusivement étatique pour
mettre fin à une situation inacceptable
et anachronique
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-François
caraco ministre délégué aux outre-mer
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre monsieur le député chez
aldarmanin n'est pas là et je réponds à
sa place vous savez bien qu'il a été en
Guyane il y a peu de jours avec Monsieur
le Ministre des comptes publics monsieur
le garde des sceaux et pour être honnête
je n'ai pas entendu la même chose du
rapport qui m'a été fait mais répondons
au fond
l'effort qui est fait en Guyane et
gigantesque peut-être vous estimez que
ce n'est pas assez mais reconnaissez
d'abord l'effort qui est fait qui est
fait en matière de sécurité et pas
seulement sur l'aéroport de Cayenne qui
est fait en matière de sécurité partout
qui est fait je rappelle au profit de la
collectivité territoriale auquel
monsieur atteint la bien voulu accorder
encore cette année 40 millions d'euros
en plus juste comme ça pour permettre à
la Guyane à la collectivité territoriale
de Guyane d'être responsable et
raisonnable maintenant sur tout ce que
vous dites surtout ce que vous dites le
président de la République le 7
septembre a lancé un processus le
processus qui fait suite à l'appel de
Ford de France Monsieur le Président
servile se rendra à Paris le 18 ou le 19
octobre pour lancer un tutu personnel
avec le ministre de l'Intérieur et
moi-même ce processus
juste comment
j'essaye de répondre à Monsieur Melchior
monsieur Melchior monsieur Melchior
castor pendant mais le cœur c'est la
Réunion monsieur castor vous savez bien
ce qui se fait vous savez ce qui se fait
et ça vous fait de la peine de ne pas le
reconnaître et ça me fait de la peine
aussi
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
à Monsieur Jean-Marc ZZ pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à Christophe BECHU
ministre de la transition écologique et
la cohésion des territoires sécheresse
canicule feu de forêt tempête l'été que
nous avons vécu nous rappelle en période
nécessité d'agir en faveur de la
protection de notre planète au côté de
la première ministre monsieur le
ministre vous n'avez pas ménagé vos
efforts pour agir avec conviction
c'est tout le sens de l'action que vous
menez pour allier sobriété et
développement durable en faisant de
l'aménagement durable du territoire une
prière une priorité absolue cette
priorité passe par une planification
écologique ambitieuse impliquant chaque
pente de la société chaque territoire et
en ne laissant personne de côté cette
planification va la préservation des
soldes de l'air et de la biodiversité en
passant par l'eau ressources
essentielles à la vie d'ailleurs vous
avez fait le choix avec la secrétaire
d'État Bérengère Couillard de Marseille
comme lieu pour annoncer le lancement du
premier chantier de la planification
écologique consacrée à la gestion de
l'eau vous avez fait le choix de venir à
Saint-Chamas sur les temps de Berre
pépites écologique pour illustrer votre
volonté de régler des problèmes problème
les plus épineux en matière de conflit
des usages de l'eau alors Monsieur le
Ministre pouvez-vous nous indiquer
comment le gouvernement entend mettre en
oeuvre concrètement cette planification
écologique et au-delà de ce premier
chantier de l'eau faire de la
planification écologique un succès
permettant de répondre aux défis de
notre siècle je vous remercie merci
beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Christophe Bachut ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre monsieur le président zoulesi
accélérez la transition écologique pour
faire en sorte à la fois de répondre à
nos engagements climatiques de notre
pays préserver l'habitabilité de notre
planète en rayer le déclin de la
biodiversité ce sont les deux axes
principaux de la feuille de route qui
m'a été assignée par la première
ministre
dans ce domaine je vous remercie d'avoir
rappelé ce qui s'est tenu il y a
quelques jours et le choix de Marseille
était pas totalement étranger à votre
présence là-bas sur le lancement de ce
premier chantier qui va être accompagné
d'une vingtaine d'autres pour arriver à
une feuille de route de la planification
écologique à la fin de cette année qui
conformément aux engagements du
Président Macron sera présenté par la
première ministre ou en sommes-nous
à la minute où nous parlons nous sommes
à 23% de baisse des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre par rapport à 1990
le rythme de baisse des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre a doublé au cours du
dernier quinquennat par rapport au
quinquennat précédent 12% contre un peu
plus de 5
mais nous devons doubler à nouveau le
rythme de baisse de ses émissions pour
être au rendez-vous des engagements que
notre pays a signé pour le faire nous
allons lancer en parallèle un certain
nombre de conférences avec des parties
prenantes non pas pour faire un
diagnostic mais pour arrêter des mesures
qui seront présentées avec un budget
avec un calendrier à la fin de l'année
et chaque grand secteur émetteur va être
concerné à la hauteur de ses émissions
le transport pour 30% l'agriculture
l'énergie l'industrie la consommation en
oubliant pas la préservation de la
biodiversité qui ne doit pas être
l'angle mort de notre politique de
décarbonation dans tous ces domaines
l'enjeu ce sera précisément d'avoir des
mesures concrètes visibles qui soit
chiffrées en termes de diminution
carbone pour au-delà des mots et des
pirouettes engager notre pays qui fait
partie de la vingtaine qui a amorcé sa
baisse des missions sur le chemin
indispensable sur lequel nous sommes
engagés
beaucoup Monsieur le Ministre la parole
est à madame Isabelle Périgot pour le
groupe les républicains
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de la
transition énergétique madame la
ministre depuis plusieurs jours nous
avons tout entendu concernant votre
appel à la sobriété énergétique comme la
nécessité de porter des col roulés
plutôt que d'allumer le chauffage si
cela en fait rire certains sachez que ce
n'est pas le cas de 30% de consommateurs
dépendant d'une énergie au fioul et au
bois oui madame la Première ministre a
précisé dernièrement que le chèque
exceptionnel a laissé tendre aux
personnes se chauffant à ces énergies
pouvant aller jusqu'à 200 euros pour les
foyers les plus modestes après avoir été
oubliés tout ce temps et même si cette
aide va quelque peu soulager certains
foyers l'accompagnement de ces ménages
reste encore insuffisants en quoi en
est-il de l'accompagnement des 27000
communes qui ne sont pas raccordés au
gaz naturel lorsque l'on pense que le
prix des granules de bois à triplés
passant de 5 euros les 15 kg
après ce que 15 euros sur certains
territoires comme en Seine-et-Marne ont
peut imaginer à quel point ces 200 euros
d'aide et seulement pour certains sont
une goutte d'eau dans un océan
2200 euros l'année pour se chauffer
voilà ce quoi et confrontés les Français
madame la ministre de nombreux citoyens
associations vous ont interpellé sur ce
sujet depuis plusieurs années votre
gouvernement a poussé les consommateurs
à passer au bois et au granules pour se
chauffer désormais en plus de cette
hausse exorbitante des prix ils sont
rationnés quand allez-vous étendre le
bouclier tarifaire au chauffage au bois
granules et au fioul vous attendez des
Français un effort collectif mais cet
effort ne pourra être fourni sans
contrepartie sachez que la solidarité ne
s'obtient jamais en laissant les
citoyens sur le bord du chemin
merci je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires
[Musique]
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre madame la députée Périgot vous
avez raison de pointer le fait que nous
connaissions une augmentation importante
de la valeur des collègues qui
s'expliquent effectivement par le fait
qu'un grand nombre de nos concitoyens
ont entamé l'abandon de leur poils ou de
leur chaudière gaz pour choisir un mode
qui nous permettent d'accélérer la
décarbonation
43% de progression d'installation de
poils 121% d'augmentation de chaudière
ce sont les chiffres de l'année 2021
vous ajoutez à cela la hausse des prix
qui est liée à la hausse des coûts du
transport à la hausse des matières
premières et à la hausse de la demande
et vous comprenez pourquoi nous avons
dans ce domaine effectivement une hausse
particulièrement sensible
dans le cadre du chèque qui a été mis en
place en décembre 2021 de 100 euros par
le gouvernement c'est 100 euros sont
disponibles quel que soit le mode de
chauffage retenu par les Français ça
c'était la décision de 200 de décembre
2021 et ses chèques sont encaissables
jusqu'au 31 mars 2023 l'annonce par la
première ministre d'un chèque pour les
12 millions de ménages qui sont
concernés par une aide de 100 ou de 200
euros vaut là aussi pour tous les modes
de chauffage à cela s'ajoute ce qui a
été annoncé par Elizabeth borne le 26
septembre un chèque bois spécifique pour
accompagner les menages qui sont
concernés par ces pellets et je voudrais
nous inviter sur ces sujets madame la
député à tous balayé devant notre porte
il n'y a pas si longtemps et au début
même de cette séance certains ici ont
rappelé que c'était grâce à eux qu'il y
avait des aides pour ceux qui se
chauffent au fioul
peut-être que les mêmes auraient pu être
inspiré d'inclure dès ce moment-là les
pellets bois pour faire en sorte
aujourd'hui de nous reprocher ce qui n'a
pas été mis en place il y a dans ce
domaine là aussi entre le discours qui
consiste à protéger les Français et
celui consiste à protéger les devoirs
plus manifestement un double discours
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors il y a 6 secondes pour Madame
Perigaud oui monsieur le ministre
qu'importe vos arguments ce sont bien
les Français qui jouent le rôle qui sont
pénalisés il faut faire preuve de bon
sens j'insiste merci beaucoup la parole
est à Madame Francesca Pasquini pour le
compte écologiste
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Éducation nationale cette
assemblée a réuni aujourd'hui la
première réunion de la délégation au
droit des enfants après une rentrée
scolaire placée sur le signe de la
pénurie il était temps que cette
délégation voit le jour car
quotidiennement les droits des enfants
en situation de handicap sont bafoués en
France lequel de mes collègues ici
présent n'a pas été interpellé pour le
défendre le cas d'un ou plusieurs élèves
qui n'ont pas d'Ash pour les accompagner
dans leur scolarité nous le sommes tous
de façon quotidienne chaque jour l'accès
à l'école de ses élèves est mise à mal
par le manque d'aesh il n'y a selon les
chiffres de votre ministère qu'un
accompagnant pour quatre élèves un pour
quatre en situation de handicap dans
notre pays et 97% des accompagnants
subissent un temps partiel forcé chaque
jour la France contrevient au droit de
l'éducation pour tous ce droit
fondamental scellé par notre
Constitution et par la Convention
internationale des droits des enfants la
Défenseur des droits est fréquemment
saisie de cette question et décrit ce
sont ces mots une situation de bricolage
chaque jour se manque d'aosh fait
grandir la souffrance et le sentiment
d'abandon que ressentent 430 000
familles en détresse 430 000 enfants
dans le besoin
119000 aesh exerçant dans des conditions
inacceptables cette injustice cache
aussi une inégalité de genre je ne vous
apprends rien en vous disant que 92% des
resh sont des femmes mais sachez aussi
que quand l'école est défaillante ce
sont les maires de ses enfants qui
sacrifient leur carrière professionnelle
leur vie sociale parfois même les autres
enfants de la fratrie c'est indigne pour
notre pays ma question est donc simple
monsieur le ministre que prévoyez-vous à
court terme pour mettre fin à cette
situation d'urgence absolue pensez-vous
que la création de 4000 postes sans
statut pérenne de la fonction publique
et avec un salaire au lance-pierre
suffiront à rétablir les droits de
enfants dans notre pays je vous remercie
madame la députée je vous remercie
d'avoir rappelé la création de la
délégation au droit de l'enfant qui a eu
sa réunion constitutive aujourd'hui je
remercie l'ensemble des présidents de
groupe qui s'étaient prononcé
favorablement la création de cette
délégation en conférence des présidents
et je salue sa nouvelle présidente
fraîchement élue madame Perrine boulet
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse merci madame
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée en effet le
système scolaire accueille plus de 430
000 élèves en situation de handicap et
c'est un motif de satisfaction et de
fierté pour celles et ceux qui
s'occupent de ses enfants c'est une
croissance de 6 à 10% par an c'est
considérable face à cela nous mobilisons
des moyens importants avec le
recrutement de plus de 130 000 aesh 4000
ont été recrutés à la rentrée 4000 le
seront peut-être l'année prochaine si
toutefois vous la prouvez c'est
considérable néanmoins il faut
reconnaître que la croissance continue
du nombre d'aesh ne peut pas être la
seule réponse aux besoins des élèves en
situation de handicap on ne peut pas
imaginer un aesh pour
chaque élève en situation de handicap il
y a des situations variables qui
nécessitent des réponses variées et
c'est pour cela que nous voulons entamer
avec ma collègue Geneviève dariussec une
phase de concertation et de réflexion
avec les acteurs de l'école inclusive
elle se tientra justement dans la foulée
de la Conférence interministérielle sur
le handicap qui va avoir lieu dans deux
jours les critères de notification et
l'évaluation des besoins des élèves les
relations aussi avec les MDPH la
diversité des formes d'accompagnement
sont autant de leviers sur lesquels nous
devons agir un grand pas va vous être
proposé dès le PLF 2023 pour mieux
prendre en compte les situations de
travail des aesh en attendant madame la
députée notre objectif est bien de
poursuivre les avancées de l'inclusion
des enfants en situation de handicap et
d'assurer le meilleur accompagnement
possible
au sein de l'école de la République
je vous remercie monsieur le maignier
sur la parole est à Madame Agnès car
elle pour le groupe horizon merci madame
la Présidente ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre chargé des comptes
publics
amplifié par la guerre en Ukraine la
très forte augmentation des prix de
l'énergie mais notre économie sous
tension le gouvernement a su apporter
des solutions rapides et pragmatiques
pour empêcher pour que les factures
d'énergie des Français explosent le
bouclier énergétique est déployé depuis
la fin 2021 c'est un effort inédit
consenti pour protéger nos concitoyens
en 2023 la hausse sera limitée à 15%,
bien moins que chez nos voisins
européens les entreprises dans nos
territoires doivent également faire face
à cette flambée des prix là encore des
dispositifs de soutien permettent de les
accompagner celles qui emploi moins de
10 salariés sont désormais éligibles au
bouclier tarifaires tandis que le
mécanisme d'aide aux entreprises grandes
consommatrices d'énergie a été
simplifiée
mais pour les entreprises qui ne
rentrent pas dans ces dispositifs
l'inquiétude est vive elle ne doute pas
que le gouvernement sera à leur côté
pour leur permettre de surmonter cet
épisode comme il a été lors de la crise
sanitaire en déployant le quoi qu'il en
coûte
monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous à
rassurer ces chefs d'entreprise qui
partout dans nos circonscriptions nous
interpelle et craignent que la hausse
des prix de l'énergie met en grande
difficulté leurs activités par ailleurs
après avoir incité les Français dans
certaines collectivités
émérient à se tourner vers les poils et
les chaudières à granulés de bois pour
se chauffer pouvez-vous confirmer à nos
concitoyens qui assistent à une hausse
exponentielle de cette énergie qu'ils
seront aidés au même titre que ceux qui
se chauffent à l'électricité et au gaz
non seulement ils font face à une forte
augmentation du coût du pellet mais
aussi à une pénurie je vous remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Gabriel Attal
ministre délégué chargé des comptes
publics
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Agnès Karel vous avez raison il faut
continuer à accompagner les entreprises
face à l'explosion du prix de l'énergie
soutenir les entreprises dans des
plaisent à certains qui parfois le
contestent sur ces bancs c'est soutenir
l'économie française c'est soutenir les
Français qui travaillent et qui veulent
pouvoir continuer à travailler et
conserver leur emploi nous l'avons fait
depuis le début de cette crise et nous
continuons à le faire mes collègues
Roland Lescure Olivier agrégoire ont
rappelé à l'instant que le bouclier est
tarifaire les tarifs réglementés qui
bénéficient aux entreprises un million
et demi d'entreprises qui ont moins de 2
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
moins de 10 salariés sera poursuivi pour
les protéger il y a ensuite vous l'avez
dit les entreprises qui sont au-dessus
de ce seuil et qui évidemment sont très
inquiets face à l'envoler des prix oui
vous pouvez les rassurer vous pouvez les
rassurer d'abord sur le fait que nous
sommes mobilisés pour obtenir une baisse
sur le marché Bruno Le Maire ça a été
rappelé est à l'écocine aujourd'hui
précisément pour avancer au niveau
européen pour que le marché européen de
l'électricité évolue pour faire baisser
les prix c'est la première chose
deuxième chose nous avons mis en place
un fond de 3 milliards d'euros pour
accompagner les entreprises auxquelles
vous faites référence nous avons
commencé à assouplir les critères nous
cherchons à continuer à soupir les
critères en tout état de cause elles
peuvent se rendre sur le site impôts
gouv.fr il y a un simulateur pour
regarder si elles peuvent en bénéficier
et demander une aide qui va jusqu'à 50
millions d'euros pour les plus grandes
entreprises deuxième question que vous
avez évoquée sur les pellets de bois oui
il faut accompagner nos concitoyens qui
se chauffent avec des pellets de bois
c'est la raison pour laquelle à la
demande de la première ministre nous
travaillons sur un nouveau dispositif
qui pourra les accompagner nous
prendrons a priori les mêmes critères
que ce que nous sommes en train de
mettre en place pour ceux qui se
chauffent au fioul parce qu'il faut
accompagner nos concitoyens qui se
chauffent au bois évidemment qui ont
fait ce choix de transition pour des
raisons écologiques et aussi économiques
nous avons la responsabilité de les
accompagner nous y travaillons à la
demande de la première ministre merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre la parole
est à Madame Sandrine
merci merci madame la Présidente mes
chers collègues alors que le Président
de la République est en train de lancer
une convention citoyenne sur la fin de
vie je souhaite interroger Monsieur le
Premier Ministre de la Santé sur les
soins palliatifs les lois de 2005 et de
2016 concernant le droit des malades et
la fin de vie défendent trois principes
de non à bandons de nos souffrances de
noircharnement elle permettent
d'accompagner les personnes en fin de
vie mais n'autorise pas à donner la mort
la vie humaine et la valeur suprême de
notre civilisation aujourd'hui ce qui
anime nos concitoyens c'est la peur de
mal mourir ils ne veulent pas souffrir
ne pas être prolongé par un acharnement
thérapeutique ils ne veulent pas mourir
seul parce que oui Monsieur le Premier
Ministre malheureusement on meurt encore
mal en France
l'amélioration de la qualité de vie de
la qualité pardon de la prise en charge
en fin de vie doit être une priorité les
soins palliatifs doivent pouvoir offrir
à chacun des conditions de vie digne au
soir de l'existence 26 départements en
France ne dispose toujours pas de
service de soins palliatifs 300 000
personnes en auraient besoin et seul
sans bines y ont accès les lois qui
existent apportent des solutions aux
angoisses de nos concitoyens mais elles
peinent à devenir effective car les
moyens de développement des soins
palliatifs ne sont pas mis en place le
précédent gouvernement avait annoncé 5
millions d'euros à louer cette année ce
qui m'a permis ce qui m'a permis qu'une
augmentation de 2% des capacités ce qui
est très insuffisant il est aujourd'hui
de développer réellement l'offre sur
tout le territoire à l'hôpital ou à
domicile et de permettre la diffusion de
la culture palliative parmi les
soignants et la population
madame Monsieur le Premier Ministre
pardon quand mettez-vous en fin les
moyens que pour les soins palliatifs
soient présents sur tout le territoire
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur François Brown
ministre de la santé et de la prévention
madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre
Mesdames et Messieurs les parlementaires
madame la députée de gorsuch le
président de la République a souhaité
que la fin de vie soit débattue dans
notre société et effectivement c'est un
débat de société avant même d'être un
une question médicale c'est une question
de société et il est bien que tout le
monde puisse s'exprimer sur le sujet
toutefois vous le précisez la question
des soins palliatifs et souvent
rattachée à cette question de fin de vie
même si il faut quand même envisager
aussi les soins palliatifs comme un
épisode de soins à passer dans d'autres
problèmes
l'habitude que l'on m'aide à coller
systématiquement sur le palliatif et fin
de vie donne probablement aussi le
mauvais aspect ou la mauvaise image que
l'on donne aux soins palliatifs alors
oui les soins palliatifs par leur nom
relèvent du ministère de la santé et de
la prévention et je vous rejoins sur le
fait que ces soins palliatifs soient
insuffisamment enseignées dans nos
études de santé
c'est mieux il y a maintenant des
enseignements spécifiques mais ceux-ci
doit encore être développés je vous
rejoins également lorsque vous dites que
les soins palliatifs sont insuffisamment
développés sur notre territoire nous y
travaillons pour cela il faut aussi des
soignants qui soient formés à ce type de
soins palliatifs le plus dangereux dans
ce qui nous attend sur ce débat de la
fin de vie serait que certains de nos
concitoyens décident de mourir parce
qu'ils ont mal ils ont mal physiquement
ils ont mal psychologiquement parce que
justement ces soins palliatifs ne sont
pas assez développés dans ce sujet je
souhaite également en tant que ministre
de la santé et de la prévention donner
la parole aux soignants les soignants
sont souvent les personnes qui sont au
dernier moment auprès de ses citoyens
qui souffrent et il faut aussi entendre
leurs paroles lorsque l'on propose
non plus de donner la vie mais peut-être
de donner la mort donc il y a un débat
de société important et je sais que le
porte-parole du gouvernement Olivier
Véran avec la ministre déléguée Agnès
Firmin le Baudot porte ce dossier et que
je suivrai de très près cette partie
soin palliatif et cette partie
d'enseignement
merci madame la Présidente merci tout
d'abord pour vos félicitations merci
aussi pour la constance vos engagements
pour le droit des enfants c'est aussi
cela qui redonnera confiance la
confiance qui peut faire des fois nos
institutions je veux également remercier
les collègues membres de la délégation
parlementaire au droit de des enfants
nouvellement installés qui m'ont fait
confiance pour en prendre la présidence
la création d'une nouvelle délégation
aux anges forts je mesure le poids et la
charge qui est la mienne d'insuffler
l'énergie nécessaire à ce que cette
délégation façoeuvre utile je sais que
nous y arriverons car les enfants et
leur protection dépassent les clivages
partisans et les sujets sont nombreux
harcèlement pauvreté éducation numérique
prostitution violence intrafamiliale
protection de l'enfance l'enfant et la
justice c'est bien d'autres
en lien direct madame la Présidente mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse
logiquement à madame la secrétaire
d'État chargée de l'enfance voilà trois
ans en 2019 sous la précédente
législature avec mes collègues nous
rendions 18 propositions issues de la
mission de l'information sur l'aide
sociale à l'enfance adopté alors à
l'unanimité la délégation parlementaire
au droit des enfants et figurait parmi
d'autres depuis la protection des
enfants demeure une priorité comme là
encore rappelé le présent de la
République récemment madame la ministre
pour rendre cette action efficace l'état
fait le choix voit la 3 ans de reprendre
une place et de contractualiser avec les
départements autour des politiques de
protection des enfants mais également
d'organiser deux stratégies pour lutter
contre les violences faites aux enfants
et pour leur protection trois années
après pourriez-vous préciser devant la
représentation nationale les bilans que
vous pouvez tirer de ces politiques et
les ajustements que vous entendez
apporter pour ces futurs contrats je je
vous remercie merci beaucoup la parole
est à Madame Charlotte cobel secrétaire
d'État chargé de l'enfance
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre madame la députée Perrine
Boulay d'abord permettez-moi de vous
féliciter moi aussi à mon tour pour
votre élection à la présidence de la
délégation au droit des enfants vous
étiez fort nombreux sur les bancs de
l'Assemblée nationale à souhaiter la
Constitution la création de cette
délégation parlementaire grâce à vous
madame la Présidente grâce à l'ensemble
de la Conférence des Présidents ces
choses faites et nous pouvons nous en
réjouir avec cette délégation
transpartizane vous envoyez un message
tous très clair aux enfants et aux
jeunes de notre pays sur la priorité que
vous entendez tous leur donner dans vos
travaux avec ces délégations vous
envoyez aussi un message très clair à
l'ensemble des acteurs et à l'ensemble
des professionnels du secteur qui ont
besoin de votre confiance pour continuer
leur engagement que l'on sait important
je me tiens évidemment à la disposition
de cette délégation pour travailler au
quotidien avec l'ensemble de ces membres
vous m'interrogez madame la députée sur
le sujet de la contractualisation
principalement entre l'État et les
départements sur le champ de la
protection de l'enfance à ce stade je
peux vous dire que 79 départements on
dort et déjà signé avec l'État où sont
en cours de le faire nous pouvons donc
nous féliciter en trois ans d'avoir
réussi à renforcer la coopération entre
l'État et les départements sur le champ
de la protection de l'enfance et d'avoir
développé des actions très concrètes en
particulier dans le champ de la santé
mais je le sais il faut aller plus loin
et renforcer encore la coopération état
département notamment sur le territoire
et je remets en a déjà parlé je veux
renforcer la coordination avec deux
acteurs importants l'éducation nationale
et la justice qui seront appelés à la
contractualisation avec les départements
dans leur action est importante pour
protéger nos enfants
sur ce sujet comme sur tous les sujets
que vous avez évoqués comme sur la
feuille de route que m'a confié la
première ministre évidemment je sais
pouvoir compter sur vos travaux sur vos
réflexions et sur votre stimulation
dans cette assemblée riche de ces de
cette composition je sais que l'avenir
de nos enfants nous réunira merci
beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur Léo Walter pour
le groupe la France insoumise merci
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de
l'économie ou en son absence à madame la
Première ministre la précarité
énergétique touche déjà plus de 12
millions de personnes dans notre pays
soit un Français sur 5 à qui vous
annoncez pour vous en féliciter qu'ils
peuvent encore subir 15% de hausse des
prix pour 2023 les TPE PME et les
collectivités territoriales plusieurs
collègues l'ont déjà évoqué et sur
plusieurs banques sont démunis face à
l'augmentation astronomique de leurs
factures d'énergie alors que l'hiver
n'est pas encore là et ne bénéficient
pas toute loin de là du bouclier
tarifaire ou du tarif réglementé pendant
les multinationales de l'énergie se
gavent et Monsieur le maire l'a dit ne
joue pas le jeu sur les prix mais se
chauffer n'est pas un jeu avoir froid
encore moins Monsieur le Maire doit les
recevoir de matin va-t-il leur imposer
comme le demande la présidente de la
Commission européenne le plafonnement de
leur revenu c'est à dire le blocage des
prix ou une contribution de solidarité
sur leur bénéfice inattendus autrement
dit la taxation des super profits
ou se contentera-t-il comme trop souvent
de froncer les sourcils en comptant sur
leur bonne volonté dans ma
circonscription comme dans tous les
départements ruraux les entreprises sont
surtout des TPE PME les communes des
petites voire tout petites toutes
petites communes partout et pour tous
les factures explosent pour ne prendre
qu'un exemple le maire d'une ville d'un
peu moins de 8000 habitants la troisième
du département m'annonçait à la
mi-septembre à avoir chiffré le
dépassement de son budget énergie à plus
de 400000 euros soit plus de 50 euros
par habitant c'est intenable
manifestement les mesures annoncées par
votre gouvernement ne suffisent pas des
solutions existent qui exigent volonté
et courage politique le blocage des prix
d'une part et l'application du tarif
réglementé partout et pour tous
aurez-vous cette volonté et ce courage
ou comptez-vous proposer au bailleur
sociaux au TPE PME aux communes un achat
massif de doudoune pour changer un peu
du col roulé merci
la parole est à Monsieur Gabriel
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Léo Walter vous parlez de volonté et de
courage et on vous écoutant je me
demandais si quand vous rencontrez un
patron de PME qui a des inquiétudes
s'agissant des prix de l'énergie vous
avez le courage de lui dire que si nous
suivions les propositions que vous
faites au niveau national il n'aurait
plus d'électricité puisque vous proposez
de sortir du marché européen de
l'électricité et de l'énergie là où nous
voulons le changer pour faire baisser
les prix est-ce que quand vous
rencontrez un retraité qui est inquiet
pour son pouvoir d'achat vous avez le
courage de lui dire que vous avez voté
contre la revalorisation de sa pension
de retraite historique que nous avons
adopté est-ce que quand vous rencontrez
des Français qui sont au minima sociaux
vous avez le courage de leur dire que
vous avez cherché à mettre en échec les
mesures de revalorisation que nous avons
mises en place la réalité c'est qu'il
n'y a pas un pays en Europe qui comme
nous a autant dépensé autant investi
pour soutenir le pouvoir d'achat des
Français pour aider nos entreprises à
continuer à fonctionner pour continuer à
soutenir nos collectivités pour les
aider à boucler leur budget 50 milliards
d'euros qui ont été investis vous n'avez
pas soutenu une seule de ces mesures
aujourd'hui elles permettent à nos
concitoyens de tenir évidemment qu'il
reste des difficultés c'est pour ça
qu'on continue à agir c'est pour ça
qu'on se mobilise au niveau européen
pour comme vous le dites cherchez à
faire baisser le prix sur le marché
quitte à reprendre un certain nombre de
profits qui sont faits par des
entreprises vous devriez vous réjouir
vous devriez vous réjouir que le
dispositif porté au niveau européen
s'inspire de ce que nous faisons en
France pour capter la rente des
énergéticiens la rendre indu liée à
l'augmentation du prix d'électricité sur
le marché vous devriez vous réjouir que
nous soyons en train de faire bouger nos
partenaires pour obtenir enfin la
décorrélation du prix de l'électricité
sur celui du gaz mais non vous passez
votre temps à critiquer le gouvernement
parce que c'est pour vous le premier
objectif avant d'aider les Français nous
sommes concentrés sur le soutien à nos
concitoyens ne vous en déplaisent
je vous remercie vous avez 4 secondes de
Monsieur Walter
on n'entend pas vous n'avez pas répondu
à mes deux propositions premièrement et
deuxièmement nous appelons tous ceux qui
ne sont pas convaincus par votre
discours d'aujourd'hui à venir marcher
avec nous pour se réchauffer le 16
octobre merci
et pour la dernière question
Madame Nathalie Bastia pour le groupe
libertaire indépendant outre-mer et
territoire
ma question s'adresse aux ministres des
Outre-mer monsieur le ministre ma
question aborde un sujet d'actualité
très sensible les énergies renouvelables
en particulier dans les départements
d'outre-mer les outre-mer ont besoin
d'investir dans ces énergies
renouvelables pour mettre fin à des
sources d'énergie très carbonées les
énergies éoliennes et solaires déployées
à cette fin nécessite des moyens de
stockage pour gérer l'intermittence de
ces productions des batteries au lithium
ou des systèmes de transfert de pompage
d'énergie de par pompage les steppes
toutes ces solutions bénéficient au même
niveau du dispositif d'aide Girardin qui
doit permettre de compenser les surcoûts
bien connus en outre-mer et d'inciter
également au développement de l'activité
économique locale plutôt que d'apporter
des solutions toutes faites or le
dispositif Girardin tel qu'il fonctionne
aujourd'hui favorise les batteries
éliminant les steps alors même qu'il
remplissent totalement les objectifs
Girardin en vers la même quantité d'aide
publique au step cobatri l'état pénalise
fortement les steppes alors que les
batteries deviennent économiquement
hélas incontournables en outre-mer alors
où nous commençons l'examen du projet de
loi de finance pour 2023 et au moment où
il est question en permanence de la
souveraineté énergétique de notre pays
n'est-il pas grand temps que nos choix
fiscaux privilégient les solutions
locales vertueuses ne faudrait-il donc
pas monsieur le ministre ajuster les
aides Girardin afin de favoriser les
steps et de s'engager ainsi sur la voie
d'une transition écologique et
énergétique véritablement réussi je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à Monsieur Jean-François caraco ministre
délégué aux outre-mer la présidente
madame la Première ministre je remercie
madame Massir pour cette question et là
madame Bassier pour cette question ne
permet d'aborder deux sujets dont vous
savez qui me tiennent à cœur et qui font
partie des priorités de ma feuille de
route la transition énergétique dans les
outre-mer et la création de valeur dans
ces systèmes non interconnectés le
stockage est effectivement essentiel
pour pallier les intermittences des
énergies renouvelables le modèle
privilégié jusqu'à aujourd'hui et la
mutualisation sur les réseaux pour
plusieurs installations afin d'optimiser
les coûts et le service au réseau
à ce titre d'ailleurs permettez-moi de
rappeler à tous les élus d'outre-mer que
l'adoption rapide des programmations
plus réelles de l'énergie révisée
dans seule la Réunion la collectivité de
la Réunion a satisfait
aux demandes législatives légales
les appels d'offres de la creux qui en
découlent sont essentiels essentiels
pour réussir la transition énergétique
en outre-mer en 2030 la défiscalisation
était un dédiablement un paramètres de
l'équation pour qu'elle accompagne la
transition écologique et énergétique des
territoires d'outre-mer et favorise la
création de valeur je suis d'accord dans
ce cadre on peut s'interroger sur
l'exclusion du photovoltaïque mais aussi
des steppes de la défiscalisation ou sur
l'inclusion des batteries de stockage
comme vous le faites
mais si on réfléchit bien tout état de
cause cela entrera en compte dans la
fixation des tarifs par la creux quel
que soit le niveau de quel que soit le
niveau de défiscalisation si ça coûte
moins cher le prix sera plus bas c'est
la mécanique absolue sauf aller sur le
marché sans bénéficier des tarifs
régulés et fixés à l'avance donc je ne
suis pas sûr que ça change vraiment
quelque chose dans tous les cas en tout
état de cause
j'ai demandé que l'on étudie dans le
détail tous les avantages fiscaux en
faveur de l'investissement productif y
compris y compris dans le secteur
énergétique afin de s'assurer qu'il
concourt bien cet objectif aussi bien
dans sa dimension économique sociale et
environnementale j'ai proposé à Monsieur
le Maire merci Monsieur le Ministre
madame Bassier vous avez une vingtaine
de secondes mais merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre oui je
vous remercie pour votre réponse je
voudrais juste pour faire peser la
balance quand même de du côté de la
question que je vous ai posée juste
rappeler que les steppes
permettent l'emploi sans personne
pendant près de trois ans sur un projet
avec une très forte valeur ajoutée
locale et à un coût connu pendant 60 ans
tandis que les batteries ont une durée
de vie de 7 ans fabriquée a souvent bien
ailleurs qu'en France ou en Europe je
merci beaucoup madame la députée la
science est suspendue elle nous
reprendrons dans quelques minutes sur
les mesures d'urgence relatives au
fonctionnement du marché du travail en
vue du plein emploi